vous voulez partir votre propre podcast
où vous voulez à mener celui que vous
avez déjà un autre niveau
ça tombe bien on loue le studio sf ce
merveilleux studio dans lequel je suis
présentement et dans lequel également on
enregistre le sans filtre podcast parmi
tant d'autres la plupart du temps ce qui
empêche les gens de sauter dans
l'univers du podcast qui est en
croissance constante c'est le manque de
connaissances techniques et aussi le
manque de matériel
qu'à cela ne tienne dans le studio sf on
loue le studio avec tout le matériel
donc tous les micros tous les caméras si
vous voulez faire une version vidéo de
votre podcast et ça vient aussi avec
notre technicien extraordinaire nicholl
nicholl qui va vous guider dans votre
projet c'est probablement la personne au
québec qui écoutent le plus de balados
indépendant parce qu'il y ait derrière
la console surtout les balados qu'on
enregistre au studio sf donc il va se
faire un plaisir de vous accompagner
dans ce processus là si vous voulez plus
d'information au sujet de la location du
studio écrivez nous à sans filtre
podcast à commercial gmail.com
une production du studio sfr bienvenue
ou sans filtre le podcast où on parle de
ce qu'on veut avec nos invités date is
it chez ph quentin habituellement avec
moi dôme plantes épaules aujourd'hui est
en tournée aux états unis
c'est une scène avec un projet avec une
chair et auteur compositeur interprète
qui s'appelle ariane droit à l'écouté
vient de sortir un pc incen sinon le
podcast aujourd'hui est présenté par
notre page pétri à notre page piquionne
pour trois pièces par mois vous avez
accès à tous les balados au moment où
est ce qu on les enregistre
vous avez aussi accès à des ballades aux
vip que dom et moi on fait cela seul ou
à ce que dans la dernière
nicole d'été l'alpa le podcast béthune
de me raconter des histoires savoureuses
par rapport à ces maillots de bain
c'était vraiment ce genre de contenu
vous allez trouver sur pétrole c'est
assez incroyable comme personnellement
ça vaut la peine
on est de plus en plus à être pétulante
fait que vous êtes bienvenus pour venir
nous rejoindre
puis c'est aussi la meilleure façon de
nous encourager sinon cette semaine sur
le sans fil
on reçoit mehdi bou said and vous
connaissez sans aucun doute c'est un des
des humoristes ou des personnalités les
plus connues notre génération
on a parlé de tous ces projets parce
qu'il dans beaucoup de choses en ce
moment on a parlé tous ces projets nous
a parlé de son background en
improvisation nous a parlé de son
parcours nous a parlé de son pays
d'origine l'algérie
on a parlé de vraiment un million
d'affaires ça vaut la peine d'écouter
puis c'est pas juste dans le drôle puis
c'est ce qu'on essaie de faire au centre
le podcast on essaie de pas juste être
dans le drôle quand on reçoit des
humoristes parce que je pense qu'il y
assez de podcasts d'humour au québec en
ce moment donc c'est ça dont le
conversation extrêmement intéressante
un homme qui l'est tout autant donc sans
plus attendre écouter laisser des
commentaires
les siens tome sera pas bonne et vous à
nos jeunes arrêtés sur balles à dos sur
ce portefeuille ça vaut la peine
ça nous aide beaucoup et bon podcasts et
bonne écoute
[Musique]
alala est optionnel tout juste 1 100
matin sur la whey en wallon m'adresser à
tan tan dung flamand podcast tu étais tu
ne te faire enlever le dante agisse
enfin oui oui je vous souhaite enlever
les danses et h2 les deux à droite la b4
et la n52 savais pas avant
on n'a pas parlé parce que ça allait
vraiment utile dentiste force ça il ya
déjà 2 5i non c'est relax beaucoup
communiqué que l'api qui je pense est
cette fois fait le titre sans vraiment
rien est un jeu d'enfant et gosse il ya
des trucs puis mais ça c'était un texte
est qu'en ce tailleur extérieur ailleurs
il va être en meilleur état que du monde
que j'ai vue dans ma ville
ouais mais j'ai suivi toute la glace
carter 84 g/t grâce à l'ajout suivi ce
qu'il fallait faire cependant le podcast
à nice matin
non je connais tu légaux peut continuer
la glace est il encore joué non ben pose
aucun lien avec les anti douleurs et une
gêne que ça ferait plus mal c'est pas
pris musicalement mais en général c'est
quand même sur un principe imagine qu au
moyen âge c'est vraiment pire qu'il
gardait ses saillies l'égard des pays
devaient c'est moi c'est ça mais comme
judas avant qu'on commence mon dentiste
m'a dit qu'il y avait de la place
mais chris des fois je me mords
l'intérieur de la joue puis trouve pas
que j'ai peut-être place que cela je
trouve que j'ai serré ma place c'est
seulement si une des raisons pour
laquelle il a enlevé ce basculement la
terre de la joue et ça arrive pas
souvent mettant une photo de moi un lien
affectif et superman tout pas mangé
pendant
deux trois stars marocaines plane fois
parce que la jouer mais jamais ouvrir la
bouche pour respirer
l'inspiration continue des tops
[Rires]
j'ai écouté dernièrement dernièrement
j'écoutais dans les derniers mois
vraiment beaucoup d'épisodes de seuil se
dit confiant drôle ça me fait capoter
qu'est-ce qui sait quand vous avez
arrêté là for pi pourquoi une question
d'arrêter de le faire parce qu'on est
tombé dans une période du ghana qui
m'ont on était vraiment très occupé un
puits
c'est dur de faire ce genre de podcasts
là parce qu'on en fait plusieurs à une
soirée donc vos bouquets tous les
artistes la même soirée avec ton pour
les oreilles de tout le monde s'était
bien compliqué puis on a arrêté parce
qu'on a décidé de changer le format on a
essayé de l'amener à un autre niveau
plus on est encore en attente encore les
on al'équipe mal c'est qu'on trouve pas
de ce poids tout le faire cherchez un
endroit tu es mettons ici serait parfait
mais c'est qu'il faut rentrer du public
ou si c'est dur de trouver un bar une
salle ou un ferr studio puis on amène du
monde en studio fait d'accord dans ce
processus là puis c'était ça car sur la
glace c'est juste qu'il y en ait qui
dans sa tournée - tournée qui s'arrête
jamais les projets leçon l'autre quart
barque sur l'autre remarque sur l'autre
on attend le bon moment mais c'est
encore c'est encore sur l'animation dans
ce cadre le projet s'est surpassée
vraiment c'est vraiment un concept qui
est supérieur depuis sa chute vous deux
vous fêtez vraiment à ce concept
l'oeuvre compléter vraiment au hasard
parce que à la base que yannick va
proposer ça il me disait jaurès à faire
une émission s'appelle ça passe ou ça on
propose des choses sauf si un crime mais
j'en donne des uniffac viettel date on
va faire ça
genre table mais moi j'étais sûr que tu
es invité il dit que j'étais le roi il
bat en arrive là bas c'était tout est
question schobinger ma question
non mais pour chaque invité chez vous il
est léger messieurs ma peau claire dans
ce cas mais j'ai apprécié sa super
qu'ils me tueraient les des bons amis
dans la vie c'est facile de bien
s'entendre avec yannick oui ça y est
facile à vivre
ils sont quand vient le moment de manger
il est très pipi sur ce qui marche il
mange des trucs vraiment dégueulasse
mais pourquoi pas la vitesse qui mangent
du junk food
non non il mangeait truc vraiment
étrange comme on dirait qu'il faut que
ce soit bizarre pour qui aime se tait on
va faire des nattes chose qui va falloir
vous mettez pas de temps dans vos nature
hostile c'est vrai pas placer vanille
coffre et pas de 400 votants sa matrice
de ça y est vraiment étrange c'est juste
c'est de quoi de codes traditionnels
avec une touche de mai de l'année parce
qu'il n'a pas besoin
il connaissait depuis quand au piano et
avec cette affaire
c'est qu'on l'a commencée lui vit ça
faisait déjà un moment qui était du
moins
tellement quand je suis entrée dans le
circuit des bars à faire des spectacles
comment on est on dirait qu'on suivait
on avait toujours les mêmes soirées puis
on prenait va en discuter avant s'est
lié d'amitié puis après on a eu un hiver
assez particulier tu es chaque année les
humoristes y ait de la semaine des open
mic de noël et comme une semaine tout
les soirs il d'humour font front des
partis de noël si on veut mais sauf que
le parti c'est que tu vas faire le show
cédé 5 minutes
accueillant et on marque beaucoup plus
puis t'es pas payer été payés en soi une
activité dans la journée ou et open bar
plus beauf et est booké désormais dans
deux semaines
c'est une critique choisir une activité
qu'on peut faire du goca tour le talent
et à sa peine j'allais dire cela que moi
messieurs objets qu'il fallait détruire
l epitech en a bien un gros des foules
toi moi vie afin qu à la discrétion du
d'asseoir et d'offrir une activité
je suis super mais ce que je veux c'est
que mon neveu
c'était gentil on va aller faire une
activité de tons chocolat tout des
espèces de deux maniaques passent
l'année à 6 à écrire des jo fatiguant le
propose une activité non au biodôme nié
puis site books toutes les chaussées ça
fait deux semaines de deux parts et de
foot lève à 4 heures de l'après midi
puis tu t'en vas voir faire un même 5000
en fait le show sera un prétexte parce
que trois quarts du temps les gens sont
complètement saoul dans le show ah ouais
puis les gens des fans d'humour le
savent que ce soit elle assiste va aller
voir julien lacroix vernis voit comme
d'habitude mais
on n'avait pas assez à deux semaines où
l'on sait des bouquets toutes les shows
avec yannick france c'est ce qui nous a
incroyablement soudé c'est sûr que c'est
une expérience et sont donc rentrés avec
l'année 2013 non non j'ai gradué en 2013
fois que je rentre en 2011
tous à l'époque l'époque avancé de 16 et
de l'impro à côté ouais je fais de
l'impro non stop j'ai joué j'ai fait
beaucoup d'impro de faire de l'impro
armes et ont tué de l'impro à partir du
secondaire
ouais tu prends le parascolaire ouais
j'ai commencé en secondaire 3 faire de
profitations par hasard parce que mon
père mon père venu me chercher tous les
jours à l'école à 3h purement dédiés je
peux pas venir je vais trouver au bureau
fait que j'avais deux heures de libre
puis un gars qui est venu me voir un ami
pillages et on va se promener
on se promène dans l'école au lieu de
rester dans les salles entre l'école
pourrait tomber devant une classe weave
du monde qui faisait des qui a l'air de
bouger puis avait des chars et de
roquettes mais pas de glace on a connu
plus on fait avancer les ont fait des
ateliers d'un procès ajoute un tu venir
on a commencé à en faire puis depuis
devenu une passion quel hasard partout
serait morissette avait cet événement
avait pu lui non je pense que cet
événement soit a dit robert et
processeur mais sympathique voire un
procès avec l'effet papillon je serais
content au mexique
vous avez joué vous avez comme gagner
les mondiaux le way après on nous
apprend si ce parce que mettons quand
vous êtes arrivé à une période de ma vie
où met-on je commençais à cacher que
j'aimais pas le temps ça l'école est
aussi repris match tbh un bon ou en
argent de trois saveurs 3 4 5 6 comment
safari d'enlever à chaque matin pour
venir ici ça me sert juste à me fait
chier mais ouais mais c'est surtout ça
te fait pas parce que tu dis crime c'est
la loterie sont à vendre
avant je prends ça prenait plus de temps
que tu es décédé d'un coup tu t'en veux
maintenant secondaire 2 foot choisi ce
titre avoir 86 4 36 qui va définir cette
avance 5 26 ou 5,36 que ces anciennes
factice et tambours ou chiites qu'est ce
qui va se passer mais c'est vrai que
c'est ton a créé
ces deux seuls way puis c'est surtout
surtout dans des écoles privées ou
direct le moins pour le moins en moins
de choix avoir été compris vite comme
jamais le choix tu fasses qu'on dit le
matin qui choisit pas ce que tu portes
is as tu vas là tel qu au fait qu'aucun
choix aucun choc un choix le choix de ta
vie aucun joueur que nadal ait baha four
tu peux pas parce qu'il doit le placer
choisi puis si tu veux charger vous ça
va te prendre un autre 2 en homme venir
à l'école de refaire ce fait j'étais
vraiment un peu stressé puis l'ims
proust arriver à ce moment là où ça va
vraiment me fait du bien j'ai commencé
le foot que peut-il aiglemont après
l'école faire des blagues avec après
j'ai comme j'ai choisi ni les sciences
un strict j'ai pris finalement l'impro
j'ai ce prix le parascolaire puis j'en
ai fait j'en ai fait une passion puis
après c'est pour ça que j'ai mis
vraiment énormément d'énergie je m'étais
plus d'énergie quasiment sur
l'improvisation que sur autre chose
ce qui nous a amenés à faire sur le feu
le mondial d'improvisation avec julien
en belgique on a gagné qui était
vraiment le fun on venait de gagner sur
la tête 1 m à la star en belgique pour
faire de l'impro avec juste du monde
drôle de faune des amis c'était vraiment
le fun on est un beau jeter en 10 jours
on l'a fait en nous on est on est en
belgique mais chaque année change rien
au québec où sied pas si longtemps
julien coachait l'équipe
puis nous on était fin cinq joueurs tous
des deux jobs a annoncé garder surtout
que c'est très festif à belge et où on
offrait la jupiler ya donc encore boy
alexandre ii gaudérique if qui fait le
sac de chips a fait des entrevues avec
des chips - qui est très bon tu avais
jag t'avais barbara
tu avais une personne j'ai voulu et c
est ce qui est ce qu'on n'est pas moi ça
m'a toujours extrêmement facile et moi
je suis nul à chier à improviser que ce
soit maintenant tu me dis c'est un fruit
stahel ou improvise sur telle affaire je
suis vraiment pas bon et puis ça m'a
toujours fasciné vraiment beaucoup qui
est ce qu'il ya des moments mais ton
quand tu rentres dans une zone
d'improvisation ou est-ce que c'est
comme tu parles contrôle de deux toiles
petit des moments parce que t'es pas
conscient de ce qu'il est en train de
former transition dans un certain état
si je dire tu peux pas être tous pareils
méthon avant la guerre mais pendant la
guerre mais dans un état où du un peu
comme je peux nous sommes un peu en mode
bluetooth
tout tout tout recevra jamais les
signaux s'était pas en mode bluetooth
chaque jour tu t'ouvres totalement que
tu sois prêt à prendre n'importe quel
risque faut cueillir un aspect cérébrale
que tu mets un peu de côté dit mettons
ce que tu vois ce que tu l'aimés tu
inverse quand vous rentrez dans une
salle d'examen l'otite mais vraiment
mode il faut que je me rappelle de tout
ce que je sais depuis que j'utilise que
tu te ferme tu te fasses ton examen le
celle inverse tout soulager une partie
de ton cerveau qui votent kiki plus
logique avec l'homme est entre soi des
trucs qui part sur des chiffres qui sont
des fois tu sais pas où tu t'en vas
mais ça donne ça va donner quelque chose
c'est puis d autres sont là aussi pour
t'aider bombe à coup il ya un état dans
lequel faut que tu te mettes comme dans
n'importe quoi quand tu vas au jim dick
mais dans un état où tu vois tu poses la
faune depuis tu réfléchis pas trop à
quand ils courent c'est la même chose
que seul un procès là c'était trop de
laisser-aller j'imagine pas si tu es
trop en analyse juge est en train de
faire serait pénalement la présence en
france quand je parle c'est le pire
ennemi de l'impro c'est le moment où ça
arrive malheureusement des fois où tu
sors de cette europe effecto ou attend
aussi que je m'en vais ex lorsque le top
10 ou segment avec se hissa bouge le
lapereau continue puis les gens
regardent avec le petit voyage de voix
être en affaires
je n'ai pas de l'autre en profiter ce
qu'ils voient pointer comme t out boy va
pencher dessus
maître de danse pour ça qu'avant chaque
game on sort on tombe mieux de quoi il
ya des exercices là pour transmettre les
sonneurs pas un peu loi exact toujours
un peu oublié ta journée oublier ce qui
se passe après celle à l'aller dans le
moment présent puis pour ça maintenant
que je te dis que j'aurais pas fait de
l'humour s'est pas fait d'un procès
parce que j'ai tellement tripé sur cette
étole ou tu oublies tout également
présents c'est exactement le même état
dans lequel je me mets avant un
spectacle jusque là il ya un texte peut
encore être encore plus dans le moment
mais comment dire ça mais une fois que
le texte il faut que tu as pris ton
texte sur qui de l'impro me donnant le
show mêlant plus c'est juste et justes
dans ton cerveau pose un passé à
critiquer ce que j'en sais ce que je
fais il ya déjà sa ligne directrice
c'est juste du fun du fun c'est que tu
prends des réactions de type les avec la
foule puis les gens aiment surf c'est le
meilleur des deux mondes
est-ce que tu conserves à cordes et des
réflexes d'impro dans ton humour dans
tes textes imagine que tu le laisses une
certaine place assez haut si je laisse
une énorme place à un pro de mon
écriture
c'est mon spectacle déjà il ya quinze
minutes c'est que de l'impro ok donc
chaque spectacle donne les 15 minutes ou
juste à faire de l'impro avec le public
leurs pages en pose des questions puis
j'ai dépendamment disent qu'ils
répondent aux enchères avec ça pour le
fun puisque 15 minutes là est primordial
dans mon show parce que c'est ce qui
permet de ne jamais dans le ton devant
le pilote automatique le xenter les
rangs du fc chooz la 65e quand pendant
140e fois que je le fais avec le jeu
commence à des foyers des moments tu
pars sous pilote automatique le traitons
tête dangereuse c'est dangereux parce
que tu penses à d'autres choses dont je
suis l'objet je fais mon show mais je te
rendrai demain je voudrais j'appelle la
femme de ménage parce que si j'ai pas
appelé aujourd'hui à vienne repos crème
jaune une journée puis pendant charlotte
est en train de faire ton choix
kerry à ce que tu dis
restez sur pilotis c'est pour ça que je
me mets des séquences puis un groupe un
gros de chance mais il ya plein de
séquences d'impro dans le show ça te
permet des déchets faut que tu restes tu
restes là faut que tu restes comme un
training day fait affaire sous peu à
chaque fois oui
puis j'imagine aussi pour béton des fans
les plus c'était plus grand fan de dire
quand je vois je peux aller voir mes
10,4 x ben ce ne sera pas le même chose
ça va pas une chose facile ou et puis ce
pas le même show il ya aussi le fait que
j'ai développé show en plusieurs étapes
us steel band snatch huawei
il ya des moments dans le show qui
faisait le show s'arrête puis on propose
au public deux options
ccn est bonne dévoila ouais c'est
comment ça tu es venu c'est quoi le
regard de la mise en scène chaude puis
déboguer vertige à mon shoot est là mais
il manquait le stylo mif un espèce de
truc qui fait que le choper en ce moment
il ya tellement de spectacles sur le
marché qu'il faut que tu te démarques
d'une manière ou d'une autre ferrari
achetée sur netflix puis une musique
rime ifs
des fois c'est tellement simple concept
puis c'est dur à trouver puis j'écoute
netflix puis à chaque fois que j'avais
pas d'inspiration
si je décrochais plus à l'écouté je suis
pas un film documentaire puis je
revenais alors dit chercher genre le lay
à l'est de flex cavani fait que la
taille minutes
essayez la solution est en dessous de
tournai criminels félix léger c'est pour
ça que j'ai fait toute l'interface du
show ces netflix le choc ça peut
d'ailleurs 2006 et fin stratège et je
suis tombé sur band snatch et j'ai figé
quand j'ai vu ça je pense comme moi je
regardais puis ça donne et les choix que
j'ai les moyens de créer de mourir et
qui s'adresse à moi je regarder la
téloche bah non c'est pas vrai que ben
oui c'est moi qui peux choisir je fais
partie de ceux qui ont passé 10 heures à
écouter toutes les possibilités d'aller
sur internet j'ai vu toutes les études
pour être le fait que mon choix demain
avec lâcheté failles et des numéros que
quelqu'un vient te voir qu'ils verront
jamais l'exacte dépendamment des
possibilités est-ce que tu
des numéros que tu que tu es capable que
tu m'aimes est-on dans plusieurs
directions
ouais c'est ça c'est que le numéro
dépendamment de c'est sûr que ça va pas
affecter tout le show ça va fêter le
numéro et la fin du numéro masqué sinon
ça fait ça fait beaucoup
si ça mais pour un seul a prévu
d'imagination c'est normal mais non
c'est ça c'est que ça va ça va changer
le cours du numéro
maintenant je donne un exemple qui est
pas dans le sol mais que fictif et
herman et jeudi vraiment j'adore la
montagne à un taxi qui est juste là où
je prends mon char le monde choisit
c'est ce qui te prends le taxi ou est-ce
que tu prends ton char ça ça va changer
la fin du nombre incroyable vie mais
techniquement comment ça fonctionne
comme une bombe ce jour applaudissent a
créé la bonne technique des hôpitaux
dans le temps d'essayer et c'était
tellement complexe où tout le monde peut
voter que sont celles que la crim ample
mutsch hauptmann sort lancé le 9 octobre
à marthe écrit fait que tu réponds vite
vite ce nom ne dit pas la mort de son
père le fils puis après on a essayé
c'était un autre truc ou avec des
appareils me fallait acheter 10 700
personnes 700 appareils et licha en fait
vous en achète comme 2000 parce que nous
devons partir avec la wii fact et tout
était compliqué on est passé maître une
machine à décibels calculé balbutiements
mais dépendamment que tam et où dans sa
halle s'apprendre pas les même si en ait
fait ou je suis toute la pâte à chaque
lancer un petit on mai soit deux matches
tout devienne noire on a pris la même le
même sens presque le même sens les gens
ici la lettre les deux options tout le
temps aussi à aurait-elle temps quitte
le temple des gens applaudissent puis on
calcule non en fonction de deux coques
des parlements comment les gens
applaudissent ils applaudissent plus de
bordeaux dans les deux options ont fait
qu on fait juste option à tel
pourcentage orbitale pourcentage
puis évidemment pas d'égalité parce que
ce serait mon vélo pige monde en taxi
giresse ou shui mais il ya des
possibilités
il ya aussi je trouve que téléphone moi
j'ai un gros panneau didier j'étais le
seul jeu que je joue quand il sort je
m'enferme deux semaines chez nous dit et
où red dead on a tous un jeu de monde
ouais positive c'est fini tu peux quand
même roulé d'arudy sera prêt dans le
ventre parce qu'on est sorti le 3 ou le
4 pardon il y avait ceux y avait des
moments où tu pouvais choisir puisse
influencer le jeu que je trouvais ça
vraiment jeu comme stressant parce qu'il
ya des possibilités qui font que le jeu
souhait plus long puis en a qui vont
finir le jeu plus rapidement avec mme
aussi le show in my mettant une une
manière que les gens ont chômé temps qui
est dix minutes plus l'on fait que des
parlements discret au piano c'est devenu
tout court enfin c'est des fois comme
quand vous amuse autant que tu fais
après le show c'est vrai je peux venir
vanessa départ de la crown a voté pour
mais bon ton fameux peut durer quinze
minutes la tumeur abus sexuels moins
longs la menoua et électriques ma blonde
dit la première fois qu'on a faite car
ils se tirent un bot impatiemment ben
ouais mon personnage est mort nous il
n'y a pas de pas de deux chocs qui fait
que la vie est une option c'est une
option vraiment faut que tu fasses
gauche gauche gauche dont je dois la
gauche pillay à 6,7 sur sa droite
je parlais justement des 2 10-2
red dead redemption 2 le dernier est
sorti des fois quand c'est sorti jouait
puis je pouvais passer des heures à
juste galoper à checker les paysages
puis à galoper que la musique western
lancer des fleurs tuer dès la fin de
faire de la chasse à ces deux affaires
qui sont pas nécessaires à l'histoire
mais comme tu le fais pas c'est un cow
boy qui est dans le far west qui fait de
l'achat
vous voyez où vit tellement de vies
tellement du stock quart d'heure
difficile tu vois quel type de personne
tu es dans la vie je crois maintenant
que celui qui va faire l'histoire tout
même chose dans la vie voilà l'école
aller au cégep en deux ans va faire son
université de ceux qui galopent ajoute
je suis dit là par amour des fleurs
madame rêve il met toutefois quelque peu
fardée vraie vie mais très fort car
avoir un personnage qu'il fait à temps
plein mais c est qu on en parle un peu
avec laurent turcot lui il raillé sur
assassin's creed un historien qui
travaillent sur assassin's creed c'est
les détails qui met dans la valeur
historique de ces jeux le thé les
détails de comment ça se passait pour
vrai et pour l'ambiance que c'est des
trucs vraiment intéressant explorer
laitiers même si tu m'aimes situe pas du
monde où l angola et ont vraiment c'est
d'exilés gros jeu le team et on ne sait
pas pour assassin's creed mais chez que
met-on didier houlès d'alcool c'est
quand il débute le jeu il engage 600
personnes pour faire le jeu mais ils
sont engagées que pour le jeu alors
qu'il ya d'autres antennes dans notre
entreprise mettant à ubisoft ayant leurs
employés ils vont engager quelques
jeunes temps en temps mais là c'est
vraiment langage une armée pour faire le
jeu fait que c'est complet sur plein
d'affaires et des histoires vous amène
dans les soutes histoire de dire des
trucs historique
tu es un homme en aidant les dettes du
vent dans l'ain une commune histoire
avec les frères wright une histoire
d'avion c'est tout petit ces derniers
des mini histoire mais ces charges
historiquement puis c'est plus dur que
assassin's creed c'est que seul on ne
peut pas les podcasts mais la rage tam a
cependant tendance et vidéos dans un
autre cas ce qu'est le thé y aller dans
des classes dans le secondaire puis
y'avait pas qu'ils avaient joué à m
assassin's creed unités justement pilule
il nommait des révolutionnaires français
18e siècle a pitié déjà entendu parler
de tels noms que je me souviens poti
pileux la moitié des gueux lève la main
parce qu'ils savaient pas ce qu'ils
savaient pas ce qu'ils rangent ouest
jeunes autistes quand même je dis c'est
pas rien diverses martha prend une page
d'histoire paraît en juin on voit une
bonne manière de danser ni l'histoire
aux jeunes puisque tu arrives dans
vraiment dans ce qu'ils aiment le plus
faire le système se jouir on dirait que
tu apprends plus vite le système pas
l'école des fois les cours de sport
c'est un peu plate mais là aussi ça
devient ludique vraiment toi est ce que
tu es tu allé aussi un grand cinéma et
communication au moment si la balle
sinon et communication ouais cool ça
doit être ce genre de programme
mais ce n'est moi j'aurais adoré faire
ça découle des couples célèbres pour
quelles raisons tu vois c'est rihanna
qui vont pas que c'est un gars qui m'a
dit de voir si j'ai pu abattre et moi
j'ai aujourd'hui regardez rimbaud plus
bas taux plein car y'a plus ferme
stadistes moi c'est plus subtil is parce
qu'il fallait dessiner mode pulsionnel
et communications fecq nous on avait
l'aspect on avait moins l'aspect
technique ok on était plus dans
l'histoire du cinéma québécois est sûre
du cinéma américain écoutez c'était sans
compter le cuirassé potemkine à cécilia
un berceau qui tombe banda ya comme une
poussette qui tombait marche pendant que
mon nom c'était ce parc à ibos et de
meubles à la location potemkine ce
pardon c'était toujours des années va
être 36 l'histoire de bateaux russes qui
se fait couler le sang noir et blanc je
me pose ça parle la scène avec je pensé
comme une poussette qui tombe pendant
genre 10 minutes à l'écran parce qu'il
est le petit train et l'on croit ça
c'est vraiment le fun compris ce que
voulait faire plus et noir ça fait là
voyage voyage dans la lune le platine
grosse que la lune à lisieux l'un des
premiers films ou sida des sciences
fiction le la lune a des yeux
wallens enquête vieux vieux view vient
des premiers films
les gens m'ont gillespie souvent des
trucs quand google
on se demande quelque chose par un
podcast quelqu'un une lectrice et
washington google sur douze autres aussi
ont le goût vous avez des millions le
reste découle cinéma comme cas c'était
l'aspect communication était moins boys
- trippant je saisirai moi je voulais
faire c'était quoi maintenant le plein
ce texte est quoi tu découvres l'intro
de l'impro ce qu'une mois durant en
cinéma qu'une question c'est quoi le
plein en ce moment le pur est de savoir
quoi dire mais c'était finir ton cgpi
faire le plus d'impôts possible d'opter
j'avais encore parce que le moment si
une équipe de production qui s'appelle
le même nid de montmorency qui est un
peu l'équivalent du canadien dans la
crise et l'équipe pour gagner le plus de
courbes c'est l'équipe que le plus
d'histoires c'est ça a été fondée il ya
vingt ans et trente cinquième set
où l'année dernière s'étaient fondés sur
les jambes c'est les jardins c'est
claude legault qui le parti a way a été
coachée par réal bossé été aussi vielle
deux légendes de leur rôle
il a expliqué ken scott que jouer
là-dedans sophie caron fallu jouer de
rachid badouri rejouer et nommer le fils
droit de voir des joueurs d'une hygiène
de la tout déjà qu'on aurait on a tout
passé par la même équipe
c'était comme un peu une équipe
prestigieuse le sait gryffondor le
talent est là comme quelqu'un vaut à
elle versé laval pour le football exacte
et si moi je veux jouer leurs passes pro
junte et l'équipe moi je m'en fous tu
m'en foutais un peu de programmes je
choisis mon cégep selon l'équipe d'un
projet vraiment choisi selon l'équipe
piste est celle qui m'importait c'était
rentrer dans le mime puis ce qui était
dit et comme toi fais rentrer dans le
même tu manges tu arrives à une année
puis c'est rare que je rentrais dans le
même première année tefal avons une
année dans une équipe d'avant les
caisses des équipes écoles qui était le
crime et il charrie mieux puisque une
année où comme tout les joueurs
partaient les spots où elle partait y
avait pensé fils droite par terre et des
hôpitaux par terre une coupe
il y avait un spot clairement je suis
entré première année les auditions comme
bien c'est super j'en ai trois jours
intenses au il ya tellement des métiers
l'impôt récupère vraiment tous les cas
des équipes de sport même dans l'aliment
se met ça vient d'où justement parce
qu'il est tellement parallèle on 30 les
propylées oclaesp a haussé l'impro c'est
directement lié au hockey c'est robert
gravel que crée ce pas puis c'est ça tu
joues dans une bande de requins on a des
chars les doors qui on ne la bande c'est
aussi dans des circuits comme on sait
jamais où il est barré ça dépasse
indépendamment de l'endroit
parce qu'une version wii ont été bons
aussi je pense à lui à lui je pense quoi
youth s'ils sont des poissons -
différents bars à quai ou deux fois
cette pochette stage mais les règlements
les
les pénalités tout ça c'est tout collé
sur leur occupe de moins en moins
maintenant parce que ces maisons c'est
la formule classique elle est ni tribun
mêlée ni c'est un peu par plus copié sur
lauquet letort l'hymne national tu as
vraiment quelqu'un qui vienne chanter
l'hymne national chaque fois enfin que
même maintenant c'est un peu plus un peu
plus fruste estimé temps le 'point club
qui est vraiment le fun kit que je fais
encore chacun nous ne sommes pas de
règle n'est pas de règles c'est plus
basé sur l'europe barreau facture saigne
un cypher facteurs du monde dans la
salle du monde sur le stage d'aider des
téléspectateurs qui ont loupé qui frappe
ce qu'offre une bonne job
si ces trois contre trois aucune règle
aucun règlement c'est plus stricte mais
tant pis organique htc de l'alcool fait
de cash plusieurs formules maintenant il
ya tellement de sortes d'épreuves
je serais surpris le rex et l'impro des
marionnettes où tu joues comme des gars
qui font du des marionnettes l'impro
musicale il est presque pas de paroles
la prudence ou dame screen ça qui est
vraiment de tout le ceviche pas les pro
cuisine ou une cuisine qui sont déjà
quelqu'un qui pourra entendre ce qui
veut tout jouer
c'est du reste ce bras de fer puisque
l'humour est différent dépendamment des
pays l'humour belge l'humour français
différents accès sûr que le toit les
belges sont excellents sont plus dans la
construction donc une histoire est une
histoire quelques punchs mais c'est plus
beau que hilarant québécois ont pantxo
au quart de tour française thaïs mélange
les deux mais ils sont très physiques
je pense c'est le leur zèle ailleurs
leur héritage du mou de marcel marceau
mais tu y joues beaucoup aidé ok eux
l'ont pas m'étendre d
des chandails oui ils mettent des
t-shirts mans pour des gros foulard
donc c'est vraiment chacun son style
chacun essaie de définir un peu son sa
vision n'est fait part à m et après mais
le principe reste le même
j'allais à cache cache à l'université à
tous les vendredis j'allais écouter la
lui le rig d'improvisation universités
envers cette importation puis puis je
trouvais je souhaite c'est parce que
c'était c'est le public qui votait mois
des cartons je trouvais ça dommage parce
que souvent c'était l'équipe qui penche
et qui avait les votes puis moi des fois
je suis vraiment je m'intéresse beaucoup
plus à un storytelling raconter
l'histoire puis bild est une histoire
ensemble temps mais je vois que c'est ce
que c'est ça qui me fait triper
maintenant dans l'impro lé ces deux
personnes qui bâtissent de quoi en somme
à partir de rien et puis souvent le
monde qui se prêtent à ce jeu le plus
sans vouloir empêcher ça être sans faire
de jog un serment s'est pas aux autres
qui remporte les les haut normands se
doit ce truc là restez sur l'épreuve
universitaire c'est ses traits punch
c'est très compétitif tout comme les
pros collégiale qui est beaucoup de gens
comme toi qui ont fait comme crime parce
que ça des fois une impro va super bien
puis le lot devient possible tous les
trucs pour que c'est pour ça que
maintenant et des ligues qui sont
consacrés qassam étant je pense à la
lime la ligue d'improvisation de
montréal où eux c'est le concept est
complètement différent ce qu'ils ont
fait aux quais le public vote pas à
chaque impro le public vote à la fin du
show donc comme une espèce de pin
puis une boîte c'est est-ce que vous
avez est ce que le show était excellent
bon correct pas bon vraiment nul
puis à la fin ils mettent leur pin
là-dedans vaincu d'enfants ya pas de
pointage à la fin les lits les joueurs
reçoivent le résultat puis faut c'est un
bon show ce soir ça a été un excellent
show puis c'est en fait c'est suffisant
parce qu'on fait pas de l'impro pour
gagner mais si ça va être peut-être
aussi cher parce qu'on est jeune moins
compétitifs même temps notre âge on fait
ça parce que c'est un loisir pour iphone
fait que faute idiote je trouve que
c'est vraiment une belle idée
où et puis même même l'aspect équipe est
quasiment plus là parce que oui ils font
des équipes parce que parce que c'est
plus facile mais ton au début mais il ya
un maître de jeu qui choisit un peu ce
qui se passait il fait bon va débuter
l'histoire il y avait eu plus de temps
ce moment ils vont arrêter quand ça 80
facture totale de défaire toutes les
paramètres de l'improvisation classique
pour en faire quelque chose justement
qu'il veut plus te plaire à toi aussi tu
me plais ne m'en lasse et les petits
petite pièce de théâtre humoristique des
petits ça parce que ça me met ton on va
reparler part ça fait trop partie dès
maintenant de sarakeb trop de place dans
mon damas on a commencé à jouer à
donjons dragons
ouais
moi je suis maître de jeu et puis on
joue avec deux hommes tiennent compte de
nos amis ma blonde aussi puis moi ce qui
quand j'ai réussi à passer outre
l'aspect geek - de la patente ce que
j'ai réalisé que derrière ça il y avait
un groupe de personnes qui racontait une
histoire ultra longues vraiment épique
mais tout le monde ensemble
et puis que le bus était pas un serment
de deux tués des dragons mais le but est
de raconter la meilleure histoire
ça me fait vraiment tripé le
storytelling comme ça fait que c'est sûr
que moi mettons d'imaginer une pièce de
théâtre complète mettons-le aller
m'asseoir pour écouter une oeuvre dès
maintenant d'une heure et demie de gens
qui improvise la meilleure histoire
possible çà çà çà çà çà bientôt la tva
je sais qu'en ce moment je suis en train
de tourner avec pierre-luc funky et
sophie cadieux
dejean par sébastien blanc il ya
stéphane crête qui est avec nous aussi
vincent bolduc est la même qu est ce que
c est celle d'une mort aussi
c'est seul principe du jeu du show
séquestre sitcom totalement improvisé
alors que les ont construits trois
décors quand je le cite comme tout le
monde on sait quoi là à l'affût à la
friends avec trois décors il ya un
maître de jeu qui stéphane bellavance et
nous on est deux on s'est enregistrée
devant public pour des petites oreilles
être des pilotes qui appelle puis là on
arrive là on a pas de texte on ait peu
près tout ce qu'on sait c'est qu'on
reconnaît au personnage mettons un mini
background puis le tarif i10 bon
aujourd'hui mais dit tu vas devoir te
poignet avec perdu parce que il ya eu
manque 200 pièces dans le loyer on se
voyait ou go ça se passe dans le salon
et de nous commence et on improvise ça
se savait atteint tva
ouais tu décote au montage ils peuvent
couper des petits des petites des petits
bouts août mais on enregistre une seule
fois les syndicats peut pas couper faut
qu'il laisse tel quel je stresse et ça
va être juste resserrer bon ça peut pas
commencer à changer d pendant qu'on
improvise on a une petite oreillette où
il peut nous donner des directives
jarque et le chinois bright et si
stéphane jaequi qui comme les ce que ce
qui vous en verrez y est est ce que le
vent tu vois que ta télé vont attendre
la saisie et le monde dans le public ou
s'ils entendent la seule chose c'est
qu'il peut choisir les personnes sur qui
sont sur le dans le décor enfin peut-on
mot cim 10 mai toi pluri de pierre-luc
il l'entend pas ok avec la moi je me
mets à pleurer avec les époques où il va
dire à pierre lecoq et peu importe ce
qui se passe il faut que tu ailles dans
le frigo petit mètre à peach et des
légumes jaspis mais appuyé déguste moi
je ne sais pas qui s'est fait dire ça je
sais pas trop quel c'est vrai malade en
mode quoi ça s'appelle ça s'appelle rue
king à képi ça tu est annoncée oui cette
annonce et rue king
depuis la grosse promo ça a été dit dans
les journaux puis puis ça on a commencé
à tourner la semaine dernière on a fait
deux épisodes fois la semaine dernière
comme trois quatre jours le fait deux
épisodes qu'on retourne cette semaine
ces malades à coup sûr vous voulez
assister venir oui oui c'est sûr ces
rixes c'est très cool ça se déroule à
sherbrooke les rues king puis on est
tous des étudiants de est ce que cette
tournée c'est ton amant rien dans les
studios tv et puis vous hâte d'arriver
ses recettes d'avant titre phare ceux ci
stressant c'est juste du fun c'est le
fun moi c'est un peu stressant pour moi
parce que ça fait longtemps que j'ai pas
fait beaucoup d'impro moutons est-ce que
témoin en fait les prendre tout le monde
fait les rois sauf que eux ils sont plus
j'étais toute la gang sont encore dans
les nids guedj activement peut-être une
fois par semaine pour deux semaines
moi si on dit que c'est de l'impro il
faut six mois au punch club fille dans
mes shows un peu mais mais c'est ça sert
ses roues y est un peu fermée de la wef
estime acheter un joueur qui plaît
énormément c'était seulement montré
punch et vous n'êtes pas trop trop péché
parce qu'il faut pour qu'ils gardent
quand même l'histoire réelle tu
t'exposes 3 entraînants pièce le roi
j'ai tué trois gars dans un bar la
police en cash
est-ce qu'il va falloir qu'ils épisodes
se suivent dans le fond when the subs
s'est tournée
chronologiquement parce que qu'on sache
qui voit l'actrice est papa de toutes
les libertés que tu veux ya des limites
à ce que j'utilise tout en environnement
puisque c'est le fun cdd décor complet
c'est-à-dire tout le frigo il ya de la
bouffe tous les robinets ya de l'eau tu
peux manger pendant et il est juste et
toilettes qui marche pas mais ce serait
bizarre que tai chi
[Rires]
skype est la porte ouverte à bafang joue
pour vrai c'est quand même c'est un
décor fait il n'ya que ya pas de
quatrième heure le tchèque s'est assise
alors simple papier mais pour ça que ça
peu nerveux mais c'est pas très sympa ce
qui était tellement bien encadré et et
les autres sont là les autos excellent
stéphane il nous guide comme faut une
semaine c'est ça devienne la comédie de
situation
même pas besoin de trop pencher pour ce
soit drôle déjà là c'est la situation va
être le fun petit l'effectif quel public
sache que s'improvise l'essence et
allemands sont plus intelligents plus
drôle de seppi c'est comme témoin béton
se mettant au desserrement a quand même
temps au des stars nil
je me les pose peut-être pas vraiment
écouté les matières manet et envoyé des
montres des dettes avec des oreillettes
le qui disait ça fait tellement des
situations cocasses sont même fait que
je peux vraiment imaginer stéphane qui
aujourd'hui est qu'il avait utilisé ce
genre parce que vous êtes vous tester un
peu stéphane vous vous lancez des
courbes en mai au petit réseau la
liberté de poids face qui dit au bout de
rajouter des affaires fait là comme on
l'a fait ce genre de deux épisodes on
est toutes un peu où on se fout qu'on se
place là mais d'après le prochain
tournage pour moi je vois comment c'est
bon j'ai dans mon lit king qui est ce
que le public à une république soit une
incidence sur vous autres une influence
dans le livre tout des oreillettes ou
s'il en est qui allie attendent mais
mettons quatre victimes mission tu vas
entendre le public rit comme temps
d'écouter radio enfin ça va être un
genre de rires en canne mais on le voit
même au début du show tu vois que tu
vois un peu le public sait on veut que
ça fasse vraiment sitcom c'est demain
que peace et ça c'est comme film est un
show d'humour succès de l'impro comme
filmées de l'impro métro quand tu
regardes les quatre gardés du merci tout
va entendre les rires du monde sinon ça
fait juste ça fait bizarre chez vous
tapez entendre de rire
c'est ça c'est comme à mi chemin entre
arafat et dieu merci
soit à peu près mais ça c'est exact en
fait c'est très raide et enfin et blade
ou encore d'avoir mechmache l'élu tu
veux dire n'importe quoi d'autre part
deux phrases qui avouera c est moi
j'avais entendu dire que pierre lucarne
un procès comme si sur les jambes et une
coupe de les gens au québec là on est on
devrait avoir des des méchants bons
joueurs pierre-luc dans son style c'est
un hymne au monde et meilleur par nos
solides
ouais moi c'est le joueur qui me fait me
toujours fait part aussi j'aime
il jouait pour le vieux montréal puisque
comme vous étiez ensemble nous était en
même temps on jouait des fois contre
mais on n'était pas la même équipe puis
l'autre grosse équipe stelvio montréal
mais dont tu avais trois grosses équipes
il y en avait une courte même temps les
plus vieilles très vieux montréal
maisonneuve
morency souvent c'était comme les gros
telegraph games puis quand j'ai commencé
à jouer à remous jouer avec quasiment
toutes les daubes is qu'ils étaient
d'accord avec greg qui tu es
et toi ni toi ni sans qu'ils étaient là
aussi puis puis je pense c'est tout le
kit grec piste et une méchante etc et
puis quand je contrôle avait tout talent
y est moi je me rappelle je venais de
rentrer le mime j'étais encore j'avais
encore des étoiles des otites viol entre
d'un canadien put y rue puis premier rim
pour la fête contre eux ils nous ont
battus 14 à 0 où ça s'était jamais vu
jamais jamais jamais jamais stylée que
nous notre équipe et il s'était rendu en
finale
la saison d'avant magis une bonne
dégeler la haye a été impitoyable vitae
et éviter par arnaud groupe rogers qui
accueille arnaud il ya fils qui est
excellent a aussi beaucoup beaucoup de
très bons joueurs
puis ça c'est ce qu'ils sont mais ton un
peu connu mais on a tellement dès qu'ils
font ce sommet qui sont pas
nécessairement comme les actions
vendangées dans un milieu non la semaine
son avocat puis viennent tout péter le
jeu oui oui des très bons joueurs
d'improvisation dans plein de domaines
j'ai nommé les des daubes ici l'on sait
tout des trêves très très fort joueur il
ya nos emplois c'est sûr que la majorité
vont être soit comédien aux musiciens
vont retirer le domaine artistique
mais elle a beaucoup qui sont dans
d'autres domaines puis j'ai un ami qui
fait souvent la musique live qui il me
conseille dit une fois le jeu fait je
faisais la musique puis on est souvent
en duo de son domicile
c'est pas nécessairement des musiciens
qui se connaissent depuis ils prennent
comme une banque des gobelets qui dit
pourtant soirée avec le une telle prime
t elle
ça m'a semblé que des photos et un
guitariste avec un pianiste des photos
si les inform et ramasse le avec mon
piano triplé y en a qui arrivent et que
sa flûte à bec chez plus il me faisait
chier tu ris parce que ces genres de la
flûte dans tous les sketchs à manille
le tout est médiéval de pisé ou plus ou
moins longs montre la vie je reprendrai
son flux de la soierie plaisir à manier
ces colis est monté sur state puis un
jour j'ai fait au tabernacle qui lui est
un vestige world un profiteur nos
solides il fait qu'en tant que musicien
que sa flûte pour la formation a
gaspillé
quand même bon fils ailleurs avec son
nid et jouer sa spécialité sous des
marques et sa conjointe est très bon
segal est un champion by means of less
me gonfler mais les avatars qui est
d'attendre julie taton équipe en ce
moment
j'y jouais je joue un peu avec gelée
juillet c'est comme ça que j'ai connu
cette année promet moi j'avais fini de
jouer au collégial
puis certains moments j'ai déménagé h la
gauche de l'allée principale du bourg
puis j'ai déménagé à cholet puis j'ai su
cave une game des vikings de maisonneuve
j'ai rien à faire ce soir là puissent
pas fait longtemps que j'ai pas vu puis
je vois conte le mime de -6 pour sa
démarche est allé parce que sinon j'ai
pas d'intérêt puis allez voir l'équipe
qu'après moi d'une longue avec
pierre-luc phone qui jouait dedans aussi
c'est dans la salle j'ai vu julien joué
qu'une crémiers soleil dans le très très
bon puis à la fin du show je veux parler
de ce jeudi être vraiment bon je te
faire dans vivement dimanche normal et
je vais aller les connexions delumeau
puis j ecoute moi je comme je suis à
l'école assad et l'humour je peux
t'aider tu veux bien mais jésus bientôt
les auditions géromois ton texte val
lire puis je pense que je peux faire
puis mais son texte tellement de la
marque pas bon c'est pas drôle pas de
job que j'ai roulé un peu tweak et j'ai
donné des conseils je dis regarde
personne même ça devrait fonctionner
puis il est allé et fait les auditions
pim
moi j'avais dit aux profs je suis
regardé comme fort finalement il ya
passé est passé les premiers tableaux
dition la deuxième étape des auditions
c'est juste un camp des pro de deux
jours si tu es bon un procès sous tes
prix après les deux jours jeudi
la musique ça on va rester au pacini nom
était supposé de capable de faire des
annonces a offert une autre fête pour
t'aider mais aussi bon marché faisait
marcher parce que s'ils avaient accepté
ce jour là il serait peut-être comptable
sapiens si toi tu étais pas allé voir
l'improvisation cette soirée le locle
encore plus mais c'est drôle parce que
justement il ya j'écoutais le sujet
contactez au plus julien qui est un des
premiers numéros 5 ans en 2016 le
premier qu'on en fait je pense être
premier que vous avez fait ensemble
servant drôle de voir d'écouter des
vieux parc asda même parce qu'y at-il à
quel point vos carrières ont changé en
2016 et 2026 pythie toi tout est déjà à
l'époque ça allait déjà bien julien une
personne connaissant julien de penser à
ces petites capsules web piccoli dépité
comme noël chez les options mais
personne mais prend piles doivent ont un
style trop fuckin à l'anarchie genre
faso et quatre ans plus tard pigs pas
trop n'en faut que ça se sache car
changer mais lui mais je viens ici vous
voulez changer mon et puis j'ai dit que
je trouvais tellement drôle dans la vie
ouais je trouve pas drôle sur scène en
gt comme l'espace étaient tes potes et
postons x n'est pas toi arrête de jouer
l'humoriste y ait beaucoup de blues qui
font ça dans commence mais ce qui est
normal c'est que reproduire ce que t'as
vu ta pas encore défini ta personnalité
ou ton style du mot fonctionner ils vont
commencer à faire
l'humour ça va ressembler à un
martèlement ça va ressembler josé houde
ou à l'humoriste qui aime bien lui jouer
à l'humoriste l'attention voiliers qui
essayait d'être un humoriste j'étais
comme annoncé que tu sois toi même nom
c'est ça qui va être drôle
c'est à partir de ce mois que commence à
être plus lui même fils à sa
éventuellement fonctionner je pensais
comme ça pour pas mal toutes les
humoristes au début ils vont essayer de
reproduire des humoristes américains moi
j'en vois la dga qui arrivent dans des
comédies club puis tu as l'impression
qu'ils sont à new york des années 80 à
son supérieur en arabe
elles sont également choqués ils font
trois quatre jours au lit non non ça
c'était un calque et on va essayer
coutellier peut dénoter qu'il faut que
je fasse ça social exact c'est comme ça
je sais ce qui est drôle c'est s'étoffe
pareil je vais juste aller sur une scène
qui remplit le club parce que tu penses
à l'humour tu penses à un million
d'affaires que tu as déjà vu le t1 lyon
codes du kanem te dire je essayer de pas
être influencé ses jouets c'est de
rester une version de moi là dedans mais
comme parent ou dû commencer qui toi tu
y es qui toi sur scène ce que j'ai
commencé à fermer ton c'est que j'ai
changé mon me sujet d'écriture fait
avant j'écrivais je faisais mon qu'est
ce qui est drôle cette semaine mais ton
qui s'est passé dans l'actualité plus
une fois que tu trouve quelque chose de
l'actualité et essaie de le mettre un
peu à ta sauce ou des fois j'ai des fois
je n'ai pas d'idée de sujets plus porté
sur des sujets vraiment cave
t je me dis me semble on parle pas assez
de jus pour les oiseaux plus que des
doutes quand j'ai créé un numéro sur les
oiseaux parce que j'avais jusque 100
parle pas assez des oiseaux y avait des
bonnes en fait ce que j'avais vu des
proches aidants rue j'avais vu des
itinérants peu plus loin y avait une
maison roazhon puis comme théorie et des
oiseaux qui ont des résidences
secondaires prévenu
et disent y tenez là quand j'étais gamin
je vois autre pas besoin de reconstruire
des maisons ils se démerdent sens
capable mais est-ce qu'ils magasinent
leur cavale en voiture comme des
courtiers immobiliers le pire à la
commanderie si comme vous pouvez voir y
aurait la place pour des graines un peu
partout ce morceau de beaupuy veut
mettre dessus mais faites attention
quartier beaucoup de corbeaux sortie
toute seule allusion racisme plus tôt
j'avais écrit toute allure là dessus
puisque moi mais ils manquent de quoi
puis c'est un prof qui me disait amener
à l'école nationale de l'humour
sélectionnés qui me dit quand tu vas sur
ça il faut que tu aies l'urgence d'aller
sur scène c'est ce qui va définir ton
style et est ce que tu as dit puis après
j'ai commencé à le faire c'est fallait
quelque chose d'urgent dit qu'en mettant
un espace de 40 à jour ni pts a hâte de
voir tes amis pour leur dire est qu tu
ne crois pas vous allez 2 jamais deviner
ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
puis tu en parles tu es passionné parce
que les crimes s'était fait rentrer
dedans mettons sur l'autoroute et
l'urgence d'en parler juste garder ça
pour toi 30 chez voûte appelle tes
parents tu fais mais je souhaite rentrer
dedans fait que c'est cette énergie là
qu'il faut utiliser a précisé ce que je
faisais ce que je faisais quand je monte
sur scène avec un nouveau numéro
il faut l'urgence d'en parler au monde
faut que ça sorte
puis quand ça sort tu penses pas aux
codes ou c'est que tu le sors puisque le
sas des gens déjà dorsale et j'en ris
parce qu'ils sentent que sont
privilégiés qui tentant de parler d'un
truc qui vient de se passer ou qui s'est
passé deux jours après celle de
reproduire pendant plusieurs soirs dans
l'année mais le premier gel c2c le sait
le plus fort accent vous savez pas ce
qui vient justement après j'ai chargé
mon écriture où j'écrivais plus mettons
à la vente dans ce que je faisais là
j'ai une longue période d'écriture pour
mon show puisque je vais et je me levais
le matin je déjeunais le jeu faisait
quelque chose je le sois jallet soit
j'allais chez pas sortait pour voir des
amis où je faisais une activité je fais
du vélo jallet j'allais faire de
l'escaladé
ça me tentait j'appelais du monde faire
quelque chose puis après je réfléchis
puis écrivait sur ce que j'ai observé ou
ce que j'ai vu ou ce que j'ai lu ou des
fois si je regarde un film je regarde un
documentaire j'écrivais papa ça je me
laissais mettons de trois heures de
l'après midi jusqu'à six heures du soir
pour écrire un numéro ip la pression
j'avais soulevé puis allez jouer piste
est comme ça tous les jours
mais là il fallait que tu joues ce que
tout ce que tu as fait dans ta journée
il est à nantes le lendemain ça
conditionne à mais les choses que tu es
dans ta journée sont quand même limité
ouais mais c'est pour ça qu'il faut que
tu ailles plus loin vraiment dans
l'analyse plus parce que si mes dont tu
vois à l'épicerie ça ce n'était pas de
sa vodka sa faute la marque us et
troisième charge de ça pour être venu à
l'épicerie joie robe en numéro mais mais
love top observe observe les gens dans
l'épicerie d'offres sortis ces seuls ce
que je te dis jamais ton tantôt le fatah
dit bluetooth mais la démarche c'est la
couleur de l'intérieur de ta bouche un
fake faux petit maître dans cet état là
comme quand tu sais que tu as un numéro
à écrire qui allait aller au gym ça peut
sembler anodin mais quand tu arrives là
avec cette éthologue observe tout ce que
tu peux voir des choses drôles des
comportements que je peux analyser que
jean devant les deux autres sortants
soit salaires et pas de casse les deux
tarés je suis à votre lot tout
et puis un jour c'est le sait le plus le
fun maintenant dans la job si cette
partie l'homme c'est vrai que c'est que
c'est vraiment l'fun la tournée j'ai eu
énormément de plaisir puis je combler
mais cette partie là où tu créé quelque
chose où ce mode de vie leur jeu se
lever écrire jouer le ver jouer c'est
particulièrement cool maintenant
montréal il ya tellement de soirée
d'humour que tu peux jouer deux trois
fois par soir tu fous ça c'est
incroyable
et puis comment est ce que la transition
vers le le jeu s'est fait valoir le ce
soit va avoir le jeu de comédien c'est
fait
ça c'est fait ça se fait ça serait comme
naturellement à partir du monde d'une
formation d'un pro ouais c'est de
l'impro c'est du je te tue joujou
plusieurs personnages dans une soirée où
plusieurs situations tous cas pas texte
puis la majorité des bons humoristes qui
ont fait d'elle un procédé peuvent être
des comédiens ou vice versa moi dès que
je vois pas trop la différence entre
comédiens humoristes un sens quand tu
montes sur scène tu joues tu fais un
spectacle d'une heure et demie avec ton
texte puis tu varie d émotions tues
varie les textes de leur est tout pour
moi c'est comme une fête du jeu qu'il
ait dit ceci n'est que les dix aussi
beaucoup qui font qu mais les humoristes
ou voler nos jobs de comédiens comme non
on n'a peut-être pas de formation
classique mais on joue le nom était bon
je dirais pas important background on
s'en fout au sdk peines et crédible
c'est d'abord de tenir en haleine une
salle pendant une heure et demie pour
moi c'était un comédien c'est que tu te
lèves une performance vraiment la
transition s'est faite assez logiquement
chez sûr je faisais des petites affaires
du petit film étudiant au cégep herman
et gpon imed qui était le plus gros
contrat
pendant quatre ans j'ai fait ça ou tard
j'ai passé de faire un peu d'impro
gauche et la droite des 30 40 pages par
jour de texte ou si toi qui es
personnage principal une émission porte
au nom encore une grande pression mais
c'était cet effort après ça il faut une
un gros rôle au départ le président
facile de
de monter les échelons parce que tu es
habitué du jour où il devait passer à
l'époque les deux heures qu'est ce qui
se passe ça qu'on m'offre une saison on
compte 6 passes et à l'arrière saison
j'ai beaucoup de souvenirs passés ça
facilite puis c'était intense
si j'étais trop jeune je pense pour j'ai
trop jeune pour une aussi grosse bêtise
de bons salaires fit sortait de l'école
george-sand j'avais quatre pièces là
sincèrement j'arrive à leur 4 4 cache en
dessous de mon lit je vivais avec trois
autres humoristes comme on avait un pot
de beurre de pinottes à quatre pieds
c'était quasiment j'aurais y jeter vu
prendre des du qr on ne décide pas en
prendre une
et comme non mais j'en ai pris une
demi-heure que je peux la rajouter à ce
volet de la bouffe nous ont mangés paul
ont été vraiment à familles jeunes
enfermés
je vais fermer dès fois toute la fin de
semaine puis georges avec un pot de
beurre de pinottes puis genre deux
paquets de clopes janvier les clubs tout
ce que je sais écrire écrire écrire
écrire puis j'allais jouer dans les bars
tared importer payer 25 pièces ce qui
peut quitter vraiment pas beaucoup plus
de droits de peuples fillon grattait
pour trois points pour se nourrir
philo tout d'un coup je passe une
audition puis antique entendent été
rendu à nourrir avec la troisième porte
le voile des filets d'un contrat ou
voulu être une très bonne charge
d'argent plus on se retrouve avec
beaucoup d'argent pour ses palaces tata
je crois j'avais encore 21 22 ans
montait à 22 ans on donne
je chute lors des essais libres et c'est
plus qu'à voter je m'achète une chaîne
en arabe à mourenx bayou beaucoup de
champagne
c'est dur de jumeler mettons le travail
vraiment difficile à 6,8 lève à 4h30 ce
matin tu tournes et je vais avec les
cercles weather de jumeler les deux
c'est sa compagne le soir le soir que tu
travailles pas tu sortais l'utilité
c'était puis en plus toutes les femmes
est encore au stade réflexe de gens qui
peuvent tout aux autres jeux lego ce
soir je vous paye toute la presse
vous êtes un soulier toit jantes acheter
des souliers s'est rendu deux mécènes
pour une nouvelle télé c'est beau j'ai
tout fait pendant un an
j ai vu que je t'invite à ce que je
faisais là tu viens quoi respect on se
paie tout plissé marrade on devrait tous
les humoristes ont cette histoire-là de
la période soit gold cette période déjà
jaipat des job parce que je le fais de
l'humour mais je mangeais peau je
faisais je sais écrire que j'allais
jouer latrille open mic lesoir be on
dirait que c'est ici quasiment un
prérequis d'avoir vécu ce pour après se
passer lors des temps personnellement je
pense que oui je pense qu'il faut que tu
graines dans la vie pour pouvoir être
capable de parce qu'il faut que tu
réalises que tu as pour réaliser ce que
t'es foutu les polluent moins
quand tu as toujours eu quelque chose
c'est dur de comprendre que tu peut le
perdre tu le puf axa est vraiment fort
pour rester le sait s'appuie plus tu
travailles fort quelque chose c'est ce
que tu veux le chérir que tu veux le
garder et puis tu vas en prendre soin et
malheureusement ça se perd c est quand
ils disent rappelle toi toujours d'où tu
viens c'est une des phrases du plus
important dans n'importe quel métier
parce que les gens ont tendance à
oublier
tu finis par part c'est normal le temps
fait oublie les choses peut être oublié
tu viens tu arrives à avoir un
comportement qui fit plus avec nous on
ne voit que débuter et il ya des gens
leur faut déjà qu'ils ont pas eu à
souffrir
nous a sonné si on est dans des bonnes
conditions et des bon parent qui des
killers qui avait dû cage puis
maintenant quand ils veulent maintenant
faire du mot évidemment que aussillon
mais on leur pardonnera pas vécu dans la
rue fait qu'il peut pas ne pas faire du
rap s'était jamais dit les drogues peut
pas faire du rap ce pauvre petit et j'ai
jamais fait d'annales pour travailler ou
sexuelles on peut c'est juste que c'est
juste que tu seras pas très outillé pour
conseiller la fête du loup bois la fête
dit tout le monde peut faire ce qu'il
veut mais c'est sûr que je compatis
comparativement à d'autres humoristes
puis une boucle discret mais dit ça
comment se fait que ça va être des
affaires puis commencer que tout est
rendu loeb pour nous puisque comme moi
mais parce que on vient pas du même
milieu on n'a pas eu les mêmes et même
six mois je me suis enfermé pendant des
semaines à écrire des jobs pierre mangé
des pinottes faire fumer des clopes à ce
que j'avais frais depuis les clubs pour
me réchauffer au chpo pendant ce temps
là toi tu faisais peut-être autre chose
peut-être quand je vois tes amis tu
sortais dessus tu es tu manges et à ta
faim et puis pensez à faire des
activités plutôt qu'un jeu c'est comme
si ça marche pas je vois dans ma foi ça
marche à tout prix faut que ça marche
bien sûr vient des parois et sinon je
vends du cap et ma vie pour ça enfin si
j'ai pas de plan b
il ya des gens qui peut leur plan b des
gens qui nous ont dit qu'ils ont des
familles quand les entreprises se fait
mais tant ils vont essayer leurs rêves
si ça marche pas ils vont reprendre
l'entreprise familiale ils ont un plan b
ils vont avoir des héritages qu'ils vont
se retrouver avec des centaines de
milliers de dollars une maison
teyon somme moi j'avais pas ça fait que
pour ce que c'est important de ya mon
père qui me raconter une histoire
j'aimais beaucoup c'est un boxeur je
pense à détroit qui a commencé à arriver
dans rues en fête
puis il ya un gars qui était le poignet
puis celle attendue de boxer commencé à
faire de la boxe puis de vraiment bon
pied puis continu-continu conduit par
mme han et leia gagner et gagner le
championnat du monde
puis devenu super riches puis devenu
célèbre pied puis un enfant un petit
garçon qui a entraîné son garçon à la
boxe pyongyang a mené à 18 ans qui était
rendu à
faire le championnat du monde ils sont
par le coach il est arrivé devant un
autre boxeur qui étaient quittes qui
s'opposaient à lui le boxeur il est
regardé son père qui le dispense je veux
gagner le combat qui sont pas les i je
pense pas puis pourquoi il dit parce que
je regarde boxer en face puis vient il
vient de la rue lui enfin lui au port il
ya pas vécu la même chose que toi tout
tout tu tues mais lui il ya l'air d'être
qui est comme une mentalité de ti faut
que je m'en sorte copies de ces sites ou
tauriel tout et tu étais tu dans ton
enfance d'où tu viens c'est dessus
peut-être confortable c'est ici
c'était difficile au début colts arrivée
au québec c'était dur parce que on ne
répondait pas un doigt particulièrement
nantis piloter pony sinon je né en
algérie qu jeudi à alger puis je vais
vers l'algérie jusqu'à l'âge de 188,5 un
bon là on a quitté l'algérie parce que
ça allait super bien la bobine guerre
civile fait que les parents décider
d'immigrés ici c'est ça c'était dur au
début c'était pas sur le départ riche en
algérie ont été corrects mais ton gars
moyenne mais le déménagement coûte très
cher des chaires de déménager dans un
coach est ici parce que c'est pas de
tout changer peu pareil les dinars
savons presque rien comparé au dollar
canadien s'est apprécié de trouver des
remèdes à la vie si on habitait dans un
autre appartement avec une autre famille
ont été quasiment 10 dans un cas
techniquement l'après fallait trouver un
appart c'était des apparts il y des gens
voulaient policièrement loués à des
étrangers qui n'ont pas de situation ton
pote aux portes de type aux citoyens n'a
pas de passeport d'un passeport algérien
mais quand t'as pas de job parce que la
première semaine très belle il faut que
je trouve un appartement du travail où
je vais pas encore trouvé de job on va
falloir un appart à une famille de cinq
travaille maintenant s'il avait dit
travailler
pas cher ces tests et oft et puis
souvent le problème est que les
immigrants c'est que lors leur métier
pour reconnu ouais mon père en faisait
quoi là-bas est mon père était
informaticien pour air algérie que ma
mère était prof trouve deux français au
secondaire puis on peut tu es reconnu
leur la prof de français quand même
france elle c'est le français nome
français partout dans le monde mais ça
n'a pas été reconnue par fouquet retour
aux études
mon père est pas reconnue non plus fait
qu'il faut que j'y retourne aux études
peuvent pas y aller en même temps sinon
une personne qui fait cage avec l'ama
mère était retourné le cas mon père est
livrée de la pizza pour pied de nez ni
avec les il y a 20 qui livre la pizza
l'autre qui fit qui va à l'école le soir
puis ça a été cette idée des roms où
aller pour eux surtout pour eux nous on
était jeunes ont toutes des frères et
soeurs le grand frère jean sont 8 et
ados à l'époque je pense que les 11 12
ans puis puis c'est ça que ça a pris du
temps
chaque année on a amélioré notre
situation pied puis on arrivait à quatre
piliers cette pression là aussi que les
immigrants en mettant c'est une fois
qu'ils arrivent ici puis qu'ils voient
que leurs parents ont énormément soit
gombami handicap que tu réussisses tu
peux pas garder il se peut que faire le
clown ne peut pas permettre de c'est
parce que je pense que tout ces efforts
loeb s'est cru cela a été fait pour
qu'il y ait une gratte le chef
concernant des bateaux c'est exact ce
que j'ai quand même fait c'est pour ça
que les prout arriverait dans certains
jeux il ya un moment où tout a pas le
choix parce que t'oublies c'est ça la
fait oublier d'où tu viens
tiens on était confortable parents de
trouver du bon job et justin
un autre étudiant québécois au cégep web
est-il paradoxe il faut que tu te fous
que tu sois capable de feeling puis te
dire que c'est ça aussi écouter ça a
pris du temps je me disais oui méditer
québécois c'était comme tu fais partie
des autres le même le même pas
exactement le même pas assez mais c'est
sensiblement la même chemise manches
talent au primaire au secondaire mais en
même temps pour pas qu'on oublie qu'il
est quelque chose de différent
c'est toujours de garder cette espèce
d'équilibré la wii je sais que je suis
aussi que je m'en vais mais je n'oublie
pas d'où je viens piqué je suis enfin
que je puisse te vois que des fois tu
l'oubli un mois mais récemment le
mustapha de shoes le malade de souliers
puis plus récemment ce jeu leur penser à
ce que je pensais qu'on estime donc de
don diamont par m
je me sers des souliers moi j'avais les
souliers de mon frère puis j'en avais
pas beaucoup de choses si vous avez une
paire de souliers de la garder un an
deux ans le plus possible puis à la fin
on va racheter une autre piste est
envers robin ce n'était pas très pâle et
nike de l'année le tavini skechers à 13
nick clegg cosco chez nous du genre mur
dessous livre je le regardais puis comme
tabarouette oublier tobique deux pieds
puis qui a vendu pour faire 4 ans qu'une
paire de souliers mais de là j'achète
des souris je porte pas c'est juste
parce que j'aime le modèle qui les
collectionnent pim donné ça m'a dégoûté
comme un fou tu fasses il prit tout
laisse ou libre j'ai donné un organisme
parce que je ne veux pas pour moi c'est
moi je me suis perdu dans le succès que
les salaires des médailles ou excès
j'espère juste acheter des souliers les
poteries pas juste une chose d'acquis
sauter dans l'index obtenir des pièces
d'art dans le même pays pauvres est je
peux imaginer le traumatisme que ça doit
être puis la porte ça doit de se lancer
dans le vide avec trop enfants bazar j'
aime dans un nouveau pays où tu connais
personne ou full sud tout et adjamé pour
connu sais pas comment tu vois d'argent
peut pas commenter nos enfants espace tu
penses pense pas nécessairement où
est-ce que tu va atterrir c'est que des
fois tu veux juste des qualités de ce
qui était une voix tellement dans une
situation précaire au tpo banques il
faut que tu t'en ailles positivement fou
de qu'est ce qui va se passer après leur
faux que je faut que je m'en aille c'est
ça une guerre parce que les gens
comprennent pas qu ils les gens qui donc
est révoqué beck ou qui arrivent au
canada en général ou qui migrent ici
s'imaginent qu'ils sont bêtes chez eux
qu'ils font et on s'envoie des ménages
là bas juste pour le fun aller voir
qu'est ce qui s'passe visiter mais en
fait c'est que ça va tellement mal notre
pays que axe que tu t'es prêt à tout
abandonner
puis ça s'arrête vous aviez personnes
qui auraient après cet abandon des
familles à votre famille parle d'abandon
ton job davantage situation pour aller
si tu crois que tu sais pas ça va
marcher
puis ç'a déjà de le faire seul ou en
couple c'est très difficile imagine avec
trois enfants en dessous c'est l'enfer
d'arriver si tu sais si tu prends
l'avion plutôt réussi peter rien t'as
pas tout et malice la tentative à lise
pitot pas de meubles de paul endroit où
dormir parce qu'ils sont chanceux un
contact nous on a des chances on avait
un contact qui nous a aidés mais il y en
a qui arrivent puis la forte du monde
sorte puis qu'est-ce que avec des
pancartes taxi qui t'amène chez vous le
soleil aux portes rien on fait quoi là
rien
on fait quoi qu'est-ce qui se passe
pourquoi il fait moins 20 ouais ouais en
plus effet chris marques fiat on a pas
on n'a pas de manteau un autre enfant
vous êtes ancien si vous êtes arrivé
quand dans la nuit une chanson d'hervé
en mai toutes et tous
oui je me souviens de ce départ parce
que c'était assez lourd en émotions
maintenant parce que tu as toute ta
famille puis tout le monde se dit pas
tout vous comprenez ce que c'est un
départ définitif non à l'enfance comme
vous avez besoin comme par exemple la
force un peu comme un comme un animal
c'est à dire qu'il comprend pas ce qui
se passe mais capable de voir les
émotions fait que je vois est
actuellement été malheureux fait que
j'étais comme malheureux mais je
comprenais pas mais c'était la preuve
que je prends l'avion fait que je savais
pas où je m'en aller ouais c'était comme
on va aller dans ces gros tubes de métal
pour aller où puis petite barbe tes
parents ta famille te disent pas on s'en
va parce que c'est la guerre on y dit
dieu s'en vont on va revenir
dubai et je comprends pas ce qui se
passe autre mais dans un avion la tête a
mal aux oreilles tu sais pas trop ça
mais ça fait longtemps qu'on est ici
plus tu atterris pic néoulous moi je
pensais qu'on revenait d'un voyage
ce sont les autres qui était l'oeil cet
aéroport une sortie les toits de manager
terminé les hommes et pauvres est le
sacrifice que c'est pete et peut-être
qui m'a tenté par arrêt de quitter quand
même s'il n'y avait pas d'enfants mais
souvent je passais enfants est un peu le
moteur de haut qui on va aller à
l'extérieur pour offrir
parce que quand vous tuez concrètement
il aurait pu il aurait pu rester piste
et jusqu'à 20 un risque énorme raison
parce que il y avait beaucoup ce test
une époque noire de l'algérie où il y
avait beaucoup de morts et des gens qui
se faisaient tuer il dessinait des
villages complet leur rentrée dans des
villages puis en ligne et le monde puis
leur tirer dessus
percé pour cette personne ne savait qui
étaient là quelqu'un c'est toujours
thaçi quand des guerres civiles se
trouve au dessus parce que ce point il
ya des gens qui sont habillés en blancs
et jaunes et un rouge ton voisin peut
être un ennemi tout le monde se personne
ne sait vraiment qui est avec qui seule
la confiance la confiance rien de plus
abbas est sur une guerre civile ces
corps personne n'a confiance en personne
fait que j'aurais pu rester c'est un
risque à prendre puis à chaque fois je
me pose la question je me dis qu'est ce
que j'aurais fait dans la vie si j'étais
resté en algérie et sastre groupe grec
le mouton l'avait fait papillon je pense
pas je pense pas que j'aurais été dans
le domaine des arts rouge projetant
serait devenu un joueur de soccer
professionnel ou soldats
j'aurais pris un méchant o'grady les
bonnes manières de t'en sortir des
soldats et avait quand même un bon
salaire puisque on sortait comment et
comment ça se passe en algérie
maintenant là ça va beaucoup mieux
c'est à dire que ben ça va beaucoup
mieux il ya énormément d'avancement qui
ont été vus dans les dernières années
après la guerre civile ça s'est
stabilisé avec moins de violence
sauf que le gouvernement en place c'est
un gouvernement qui était assez corrompu
mercier puis l'année dernière vous avez
vu et eu des manifestations ça bouge
beaucoup en algérie en ce moment parce
que le président en fait était destitué
parce que il faisait juste à cumuler des
mandats est vue comme plus vraiment de
démocratie c'est est un despote
il restait lors des 25 ans je pense
qu'ils étaient là pour moi là ont la
bosse et comme possible d'estimer réside
en 2030 c'est comme si dans l'autre choc
à chaque find more day fait je veux
changer la constitution
que j'aime pas les yéyés puis pull off à
clust on espérait vraiment transitoire
parce qu' on sait pas trop ce qui va se
passer vers des élections bientôt les
parties commencent à se faire face
mettons des gens il ya beaucoup de gens
qui savent pas ce qu'ils veulent ils
savent qu'ils veulent ce qu'ils
voulaient pu choisir ce président là
même la maintenance est convoqué à ce
qu'on on études droite ou de gauche
maintenant qu'on a le choix 16 heures
pile et pas même les partis jeudi avant
il y avait tellement pour beaucoup de
parties qui s'opposent et parce qu'il
est va disparaître ou où ils disent tu
es leur parti où il sortait dans les
médias comme quoi cette aide était des
voleurs ou des pédophiles instructive
personnes vous laisse pointer conduit la
maintenance s'est rendu - combien on
pourrait faire un parti qu'est ce que
c'est quoi nous intéresse quoi nos
valeurs se créer des partis puis là ça
va savourer éventuellement beaucoup
bouger très bientôt fin quand j'ai très
hâte de voir ce qui se passe que vous
avez vous avez de la famille la base
mais encore moins genre 95% de ma
famille tant qu est ce qu était retourné
en corée fois j'y retourne cette année
exceptionnellement mais ça faisait
longtemps que je peux pas aller ça doit
faire dix ans que je peux retourner way
à cause du travail c'est parce que avant
je pouvais en algérie parce que pendant
perdu colère l'été je travaillais pas où
vous avez des petits jobs in mais je
partais un mois puis la la comme je
travaille à côté l'été je peux pas puis
l'algérie faut que tu aies longtemps
entreprennent une semaine parce que déjà
ça prend ça prend une semaine sans
sortir du décalage sur les grosses
familles labopharm et or non seulement
le temps de voir tout le monde il est
resté une journée comme tous les soirs
tous les jours tu vois des gens soient
des gens puissent ils fondent les boks à
fond ça fait longtemps que j'ai pas vu
en plus que le stany je me suis décidé à
y aller
c'est un réseau d'humour en ag ouais je
connais pas bien mais chez que l'algérie
est un festival du mot que je vais
essayer de faire installer car on en est
à sa troisième édition fac parce qu'un
engouement pour l'humour la boj
maintenant après je sais pas comment
l'organisation en fait je trouve plus
difficile dans ces pays là prenez des
bonnes idées comme ça de faire un
festival l'organisation c'est toujours
un peu
c'est à patrick il sait maintenant
maintenant moi qui ai aucun contact la
balle si je voulais aller là bas c'est
une destination qui se fait bien pour
quelqu'un personnes sur une place que tu
veux tu peux en parler en français
promener les pieds
ouais c'est sûr que pour la langue il y
aura aucun problème le tout le monde
parle très bien français
après oui peut être jusqu'à mieux du
despote dangereux vielles dessus des
noms je pense pas qu'ils disposent
dangereux je pense juste que c'est
beaucoup moins touristique mettant
l'algérie que pendant la tunisie ou le
maroc où le maroc peut vraiment leur
économie basée là-dessus maintenant josé
luis tu vois souvent l'algérie tu vas au
sheraton est toi il meurt en plein de
touristes c'est surtout un pays où les
gens vont pourtant pour le travail de 10
hôtels c'est surtout des ressortissants
des gens qui pensent qu'ils bossent en
fait sur soie carton phone puis se
piquer magnifique non plus bon côté
géographiquement parlant le plus beau
que le maroc que la tunisie puisqu'ils
plus grand qu'elle ne bouge plus pas
t'avoir this voit dans le sud d'où ce
que je ferai le jir exactement le sud le
désert du sahara hors jeu vous aurez
toujours des idées des villes des villes
oasis qu'on peut y arriver le premier
des airbus et des paradis se promènent
là dedans puis c'est très bien encadré
c'est juste que maintenant se promène à
alger au centre ville ça se peut que des
foyers du monde fasse des petits
commentaires je bats toi n'ont fait
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de français
encore qui sont en âge et c'est
peut-être juste un j'irai pologne un
gain de 6 qui veulent se faire le party
mais je prierai plus au maroc
louer une maison maroc faire le party
qui se promenaient l'algérie au
centre-ville je sais pas pourquoi ça
m'appelle beaucoup andrée jerry moyes
oui mais ce thème la nature piles et
étendait de toutes les religions y est
tellement de relire différence pays
d'orb puis de d'écosystèmes différence
c'est vraiment un payer le faudra aller
mais j'irai patxi les halles alger
bonjour comme tiré depuis les jeux pas à
marrakech soit pas ou à la havane où que
le tout le monde est supporté et puis
les gens sont moins supporté maintenant
au liban à beyrouth mentaux sont pas
vraiment supporter c'est bon c'est bon
c'est bon
vesta coach parents sachent pas sûr que
ça fait dix ans que je parle je pense
encore tabou et l'alcool chez les jeunes
en algérie comme ce pays musulman
ouais pas de problème avec une bière là
où juste promue dans la ruche aux
suppôts super bien vu ça se fait mon
appart aussi ça les jeunes je pense
qu'ils font on de l'eau mais maintenant
je suis heureuse parce que je suis assez
petit et c'est la bosse et s'essayer à
un tiers chrétiens et de musulmans béton
métier les jeunes musulmans ils boivent
type il ya des bars puis le monde
sortent petit répit la bouche parce que
si mal même plus cachée du web c'est
moins c'est moins cachés au liban encore
un génie parce que quand même un tiers
de la population qui est musulman
chrétien dans l'algérie c'est tout le
monde musulman au monde musulman
enfin que ben il ya des y ait des
kabyles qui sauront qu'ils sont pas
musulmans qui sont soit chrétien ou
païens et des bars ça existe ou non y en
a mais sont souvent associés à des
hôtels c'est sûr que dans tout les
hôtels ya un bar même les clubs mettant
à côté des hôtels parce qu'ils savent
que c'est là que des touristes mais
aussi des petites brasseries comme ça au
coin des rues 1 - surtout si tu vas pas
dans le ramadan en plus mon lit et pour
être quelqu'un qui se trompe qui va mais
tombera en algérie par la médaille de ce
qu'il devrait trouver talent s'est
plaint le jour tout est fermé ou presque
les gens travaillent puis déjà mange
mange pas au waf waf c'est toujours dans
un resto etc sont surpris cac 40
vous l'avez fait il faut jeter a estimé
lee j'avais oublié que c'est le ramadhan
le mieux leurs manèges étaient allés sur
jean-talon puis
je voulais m'acheter un bouteille d'eau
je pense je rentre dans un commerce je
présume tedo puis tout le monde me
regarde vraiment cross quad en face
heureusement j'ai pas vu sur place forte
des rebelles armés ce qui veut dire soit
pas soit pas allé jusqu à la face du
monde
surtout le téléthon je n'ai pas du tout
le réflexe de faire attention
j'espère que je serais même pas mais non
mais non gérés aucune confiance de tous
les hommes il ya quelque chose qu'ils
savent que c'est sûr ça va
s'ils laissent leurs commerces ouverts
j'achète de la wii c'est juste que de
voir mettons que quelques cas là maghrib
à leur bord de l'eau n'en fasse exprès
mais ouais ça va couper aller visiter là
j'ai vraiment on va surtout en ce moment
et beaucoup de changements qui sont ils
font que c'est plus intéressant tu
disais que avec le travail 7 empêché d'y
aller au delà de travailler vraiment
beaucoup le thé sur 1 million d'ha forme
est ce que tu es rendu un moment ta
carrière
ou est-ce que tu peux ou est ce que tu
dis non à des affaires pour le le bien
fait à ma vie personnelle me tombe
ouais c'est cette année j'ai commencé à
la fin avant je faisais poste oui à tout
ou presque à tout mais cette année j'ai
commencé à le faire parce que j'ai senti
que ça pouvait ça pouvait jouer sur mon
sur mon moral tu jusqu'au début t'es
content tu fais des projets et tous mes
pensées l'année dernière j'ai fait huit
projets en même temps ça va brûler lui
trop géant mais moi je veux si je pense
ici ce tournage plus de deux projets web
tout dans le même six mois mais il
s'était beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup pilat le dernier rush que j'ai
fait c'est ce mot si au mois d'août je
faisais 5 séries télé qui se sont
enchaînés sur un mois et demi que
c'était juste est littéralement de
suicide
mettons je commençais à 6 heures le
matin je finissais à 3 heures
l'après-midi mettons sur telle série
après ça j'avais une heure pour aller
sur l'autre série contourner mettons de
nuit fait que je finissais à 1h 2h du
matin je retournais chez nous je
repartais à 4 heures pour une série je
pouvais faire ce pendant quatre cinq
jours d'affilée après si j'avais une
journée de congé à chaud il fallait que
je fasse le show là tu finis le show il
ya onze ans maintenant le temps de
revenir chez vous il c'est un fou sur
barthassat cas ce thème et on l'a on le
préparait mettons est ma gérante nous
est dieu qui le dit on va se donner un
boost victimes ont c'est comme donner
toutes les outils nécessaires avant de
nous on a ces sacs de cocaïne s'est
parlé beaucoup chanté comme regarder tu
vois que tu es tu capable pour tu m'en
parle
on va céder à installer téléphone j'ai
un téléphone d'urgence dans ma chambre
qui est un gros téléphone aux couleurs
jaunes sucre et la belle est ce que
c'est l'appel dirais c'est il ya
quelques numéros et personnes puis
branché au mur tu veux pas décharger
parce que tu arrives et des fois que
met-on charge pas mon cell
ouais moi je dors solide le temple le
sel vibra côté wilson fort puis le jeu
répond fait le hacker facteur de penser
tous les samedis pour ça qu'on ophrys
téléphones à bas prix pour éviter une
grossesse ça te réveilles bon vieux lion
rien comme un bon vieux le bris
c'était des semaines n'a pratiquement
pas dormi
ouais bah tu dors maintenant que tu
pratiques est ce que j'appelle le
sommeil le sommeil instantanée tout
essayé de dormir à n'importe quel moment
n'importe où
c'est notre plateau à qui est beau et
même 15 minutes des fois ci c'est bon là
c'est dissuader x 3 4 minutes mettons
ils font un peu l'éclairage je te laisse
te mélange entre chemin et puis la
méditation
mais mais mais mais justin trois minutes
c'est plus que je prenne langue tu peux
casser tout ce qui est effectivement le
matin dans l'ue baird au dos je
conduisais pas parce que je voulais
absolument que ça me donnait moment les
transports ça te permet de dormir les
scènes c'est sûr qu'entre les scènes
montrent que je mange c'est un peu plus
compliqué mais tu manges pas pendant les
périodes de dignité va dormir c'est
d'équilibrer clutch dodo prêt dès qu'il
n'était pas sur une scène qui dit va pas
fumer une top paire garder les joueurs
de dormir dehors dès qu'ils peuvent à
chaque fois ce que foutent c'est
l'intention qui sait cependant que
pendant son qui était qui gagnaient tous
les tours de france les disait javel
avantage sur toutes mes autres
compétiteurs de dormir n'importe qui me
fait qu'ils aiment et on arrivait dans
un dans l'autobus qui nous amenait d'une
ville à une autre on avait 15 minutes
d'autres de sa fin il disait jacques
rural de bus
je dormais 14 minutes 30 secondes de
sommeil profond des gens puissent rêver
le bon avantage sopi le père de l'enfant
le pays où tout le monde l'avait fait
que l'avantagé c'est vraiment décevant
j'avais pris 2 le père aulas dakar dakar
pour un show je faisais trois shows 1-1
au sénégal puis la journée que j'arrive
je pogne enfin il ya plein de trucs
plein de trucs mais ton personnel j'ai
un problème de couple puis puis j'ai
pris une fièvre une pierre une fois de
sa fièvre
quand tu vois je peux me fier je passais
une insolation schepper cloué au lit
sauf que là c'était vraiment une fière
puissance de jeu commencez à halluciner
des trucs le jeu si j'étais j'étais
couché dans mon lit d'hôtel avec une
compresse froide sa tête puis s'était
rendu que je n'avais pas dormir je
pouvais pas manger fait que commencer à
voir c'est du monde qui me parlait
piémont ex me parlait plus et comme vous
vous assurez que des problèmes
financiers en conquête et dans une
chambre d'hôtel à dakar oui j'ai paniqué
parce qu'ils écrivent il faut que je
guérisse vite parce que mon choi et non
deux jours puis le j'ai essayé j'ai pris
quelques médicaments
tiens ça faisait ça faisait fois encore
le fait que la journée du show
l'organisateur du festival j'écoute je
vais t'emmener voir un médecin son ami à
moi c'est un spécialiste or il votre
guérison
le médecin personnel cité allez je te
laisse tout à l'heure le médecin puis me
regarde les tchèques vite vite fait est
ce correct au besoin d'antibiotiques de
trois afin qu'une lettre chose de ce
genre fuchs ufo qui performent ces
experts ces mots on va doper le truc et
qu'une seringue remplie à ce raid jeu
physique où vous allez qu'est ce que
vous allez faire
j'espère faire bouger ses mecs
20 et demain c'est un truc qui s'avale
cocktails molotov
comme toujours c'est le p au p oui ça
crime parfait
ouais ouais ça peu de sucre de suites
spa de suite mais ça a pris
mettons une heure ou deux puis jeté un
surhomme dans soudaine envie d'aller
monter un col du rebond 3 4 jours que je
t'ai talk show ouais ça produit innovant
de globules rouges
je sais pas ça comme avec les
médicaments qui ont promis d'y tuer la
fièvre j'étais juste
j'ai rarement été aussi bien sûr sur
scène l'avantagent l'avant je le ferais
doping sportif le kent et maintenant il
y en a encore mais y est vraiment moins
2 il essayait plus ciblées sur certaines
affaires de récupération lemay le pe ne
l'avantagent que ça devait donner ça
devait pas avoir de sens ces foules
tu vois le des clips de lance armstrong
pendant les tours de france pendant ces
camps d'entraînement il est debout sur
son vélo dans un col qui monte ainsi à
14 degrés pendant 15 minutes issue à
l'infini comme si elle chante louvre qui
tombe et son menton pis ils continuent
genre ces gens accumulent pas d'assez de
l'actif d'ailleurs exposé ses t'imagines
logitech jeté à terre je pouvais plus
bouger chez rendu à un stade dangereux
de fièvre il me donnait s'appuie faisant
chaudement 1700 personnes le soir même
top tchèque très fou à l'imaginer c'est
ton corps est parfaitement fonctionnel
puisqu'on parle du cordal elle c'est
absurde il est quand même très fort si
tu donnes ça quelqu'un qui avait le
moteur le plus j'avais pris une fois
pour pour sauver le spectacle lui
mettant tous les jours ou tous les deux
jours où suivi par le médecin
professionnels craignent un moyen de
faire un surhomme
dans une toute grève mais en fait
probablement vous savez 2 entendu des
témoignages s'amende cyclistes que c'est
que c'était ouvert par après là dessus
si c'était elle la différence et qui
montre un col qui tue c'est normalement
tu aurais les jeunes en furie qui me
ruel tic tu veux mourir plus et quand on
subit des cars est loin des pulsations
reste correct puisque le ya des limites
à ce que le corps humain peut faire même
pendant parole et tour de france liviu
tour de france il soulève le ton pendant
l'étude et voilà j'ai vu plein de fautes
et jeux vidéo ce qui faisait c'est que
mettons qu'on peut mieux fait d'aller
arrêter dans des bars les cyclistes
arrête dans des bars du poil les bières
il ya du monde qui leur donne des droits
parce que ça leur permettait de
continuer parce que c'est d'écraser les
corses et les brûle permettant sa - la
douleur à 800 - la douleur moi quand
j'ai vu ta laval aaa à sainte dorothée
si j'avais pas de voiture je n'ai pas de
permis puis je travaille à laval puis
short et maintenant le vendredi soir
après la job fac je finissais mes temps
à je peux 11h30 au resto puis prenez je
me déplaçais strictement caen avait donc
[ __ ] je prenais mon bail que je
partais de sainte dorothée jusqu'au
saint sulpice en vélo ça me prenait
mettant une heure et demie en prenant
les décrochements vidé la cour si
j'arrivais laboy devait être jeu pendant
une heure et demie du match je me claqué
une terrible chute biard a dit piastres
claquettes bière mais pourquoi est-ce
que c'était pas encore il ya les
microbrasseries t'es pas bon alors on
allait tout aussi chaud au saint siège
de la collecte des deee les deux corps
de chien puis je parte elle me tend vers
3h30 dans le mange bien
cheese au mcdo gens repartent en ré
l'eau ça me prenait maintenant 45
minutes sans terry ne sent pas la cde
lactique tonton les signaux entre ton
corps et ton cerveau sont biaisés
l'homme et ont acquiescé comme tarnac
j'ai mal à ma voix que des trucs
nouveaux locaux continuent puis-je est
arrivé chez nous je t'ai je t'ai top
shape et ses merveilles tout a brûlé
quelque temps mais on a un podcast
icarus dans le studio c'est les gars
prennent un juge et beauté hcr de
broadcast loggia les prix ont également
acheté ici non puis j'ai comme oubliée
que j'allais prions fait que je suis
retourné chez nous puis le chirurgien
puis j'en ai jamais pris un gros morceau
j'ai juste pris quand même 10 mg le sait
rien et c'est que j'arrive au jam puis
je suis sur le tapis roulant
celle ci comme champ comme pas mes
jambes j'étais comme jusqu'au bout mais
j'ai aucune douleur aux jambes
aucune articulation qui grince rien le
sang on sait qu'on m'a coupé les jambes
mais piécourt karma découvre par la
norme c'est quand même bon ok c'est que
pour que nous avons souscrit pleinement
quelqu'un qui me vois je t'ai juste
complètement défense j'ai l'impression
jeter corps et que les ans
mais c'est raconter ma vie sur quoi
sur quoi tu travailles que tu peux parle
en ce moment là que les gens vont voir
le projet rédigé de mai le projet de
milou et que là on a tourné cet été à
des tournages que j'ai fait mes temps
conséquent les 5,5 tournage en vente a
fait que vous pouvez voir mes cernes
cette folle parce que le personnage fit
avec ketty j'arrivais mettons sur projet
2000 puis moi j'avais dormi une heure
cette nuit là mon personnage est très
fatigué rires l'accident mais pas ses
personnages trois épis ok c'est le fun
mais tant de rajouter c'est arrive a
ajouté un peu tombe donc ton vécu dans
la ville dans tes personnages pensent à
amène toujours une facette ses méthodes
le personnage de que je vous entre eux
de militer pas écrit de même puisque
j'ai un peut modeler à ma manière parce
que justement je pouvais pas être trop
hype que je les ai mis un peu plus l'eau
puisque un personnage qui plus gêné
ouais je trouve ça donne une super belle
dimension à ce personnage là on se
tourner aussi mon fils qui va sortir
très bientôt qui est une série
dramatique sur la maladie mentale ou
jouer un bi polaire un croc speed qui
vit dans la rue avec leur mettant
j'avais loupé j'étais vraiment vraiment
qu'ils souhaitent souvent gérome au
dessus et puis on tournait tout ennui
booster parfait parce que maintenant
j'arrive et là je le prenais deux cafés
avant de commencer à tourner et puis ça
faisait que j'étais nerveux mais fatigué
ces sommes étant quand tu es à des
yankees une rue d'un disque six ans
dorment pas beaucoup puis se stimulent
factice a donné une espèce de check est
tout le temps j'étais comme tu dis même
des fois les le cameraman et guide com
qui met la tête qu'il finit médite peut
arrêter le 2 c'est moi
boss votre personnage un café avec son
habitude quoi ce personnage l'hôpital
c'était comme émotionnellement tu es
toujours fragile quand tu dors pas
beaucoup le tu manges pas assez du bois
du café elle tu joue un personnage qui
est respecte il était vraiment troublé
vie à ce moment j'étais particulièrement
troublé j'en arrivais pas à gagner mes
émotions puisque le personnage qui est
demain jeudi comme intégré au personnage
après bon je tournais oscille avec moi
l'atmosphère était plus difficile parce
que c'était dur de la croise des
personnages un peu plus c'est très très
mécanique j'ai trouvé ça tough mettons
pour les textes parce que dans mon texte
à apprendre je faisais avec moi même
temps puis je faisais quoi d'autre c'est
débile autorisé à parfaire la belote
avec son origine j'ai réussi j'ai pas
comment mais j'ai réussi avec un bon
entourage pense pas puis aussi prennent
un congé au moins dans l'année d'une
petite semaine que tu ça permet de pis
si vous avez juste que tu viens de dire
c'est extrêmement révélateur de comme le
mode de vie que tu mènes de dire faut
aussi qu'ils prennent des congés année
une petite semaine dans une année
complète passent des fois dans nos
poches c'est souvent aussi expriment des
vacances et des pages et des sujets une
journée congé puisque dit victor
vacances jeudi et non de match correct
en vacances comme étant une journée
parce que c'est pas comme c'est pas une
semaine de vacances en plus des fins de
semaine parce qu'il fait une semaine tu
es saha job aussi way we say c'est même
le principal directionnelle et les shows
la semaine c'est toujours pour l'horaire
macbeth et faut que tu aies des amis
aussi que ceux qui font la même chose
que toi parce que tu es bon mais dans le
g exceptionnellement le mardi matin je
commence à 9 au lieu de commencer à 8 je
fais comment je peux aller prendre un
verre le lundi qui veut prendre vers le
lundi soir
notre tout le monde et combien on
travaille tout à 7,8 demain matin
avec ta jamais le même horaire que les
autres le vendredi soir bon c'est la
fête de tels ont fait un gros souper on
ne peut pas jeter à canal mort un show
le temps que je revienne il va être 3h
4h du matin le lendemain matin ils vont
tout déjeuner parce qu'ils vont brunch
et ont été crevés poste afin de la route
toute la nuit ces jo de gadji c'est
finalement c'est bon ben je vois rappelé
yannick de martino pitoyable à quoi on
se réjouit à montréal
on arrive donc on chez leurs tenues et
sur les thalys se voir la face les gars
on est dispo télé solde de 10 po à paris
mais là cette année je veux je veux
diminue j'essaye diminuer la charge de
travail comme le en ce moment ils rue
king sur lequel je tourne mon show je
travaille aussi sur mon deuxième choix
que je en train d'écrire
puis après ça c'est des petites affaires
à gauche perd droite j'essaie de pas
trop pour trop engagé dans des gros gros
projet parce que ça va me permettre
d'écrire sur two men show je pouvoir
prendre ce but l'autre vie que j'aime
est tellement je me levais écrire jouer
puis ça serait vraiment le fun puis puis
comment sinon j'étais d'autres trucs que
je fais en ce moment les pilotes aulas
n'était plus engagé
c'est une ode à joues le sénat j'ai
rarement sur mon show à début avril j'ai
commencé mon show on en fait on le fait
une formule différente non vraiment il
fait une première une première
médiatique fait deux jours de fait comme
un george v 22 soir quasiment d'affilée
à base d art parce que votre ex
téléphone comme com
pourquoi faire deux fautes fait deux
soirs pilote mais il ya tellement de
gens qui peuvent pas les voir pour être
habitués présents sur 22 soit en un mois
pas de mauvaises excuses de mme à
quelque chose je peux passer aujourd'hui
mais il me reste une villa on en refait
on revient sur montréal si bientôt on
est rendu à 29 chaud sur montréal puis
au total on est rendu là
du show officiel je pense à 60 70 72 ah
ouais ouais
plus on en fait 100 chevaux de rodage
avant tout à 172 ch ou plus il reste
encore une bonne 50-60 être un peu plus
c'est fou c'est quoi le on a parlé un
peu de ton de ton inspiration à des
choses du genre de vie de trouver
l'inspiration là dedans mais c'est comme
étant les grands thèmes du spectacle
vient de tuer jean est tous des choses
plus que de lui aucun jugement la
médiation mais est-ce que c'est plutôt
mal l'observation du jour de joie autour
des thèmes de communiquer ou discuter
dans ton parti tu pars toujours de
quelque chose qui vienne toi même tu
sais pas c'est la meilleure manière
d'écrire quoi que ce soit à partir
n'importe quel projet parle de toi même
peu après pour bifurquer dépendamment de
quoi je parle d'expérience personnelle
peu après se développe sur des sauts des
idées mais ton mais quand je parle d'un
moment où je me suis fait arrêter par la
swat
quand j'étais à l'école nationale de
l'humour cause d'un tournage on s'est
fait arrêter dans l'école pied mais moi
je vous souhaite arrêter puis de ceux de
ce numéro là je découvre sur les tueries
aux états unis le jeune numéro complet
sur sur les tueries dans les états unis
et celle dans les écoles ce que tu vas
me dis-je sur des pourcentages
alors ce que j'offre une solution et le
i ce qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on pourrait
faire pour diminuer les tueries aux
states fax et comme tout ça c'est 20 25
minutes mais ça part d'une expérience
personnelle puis là dessus c'est ce que
j'ai trébuché dans rue ouais mais c'est
parce que il ya peut-être pas assez de
sel dans les rues ou à mais en même
temps c'est des travailleurs qui sont
pas supprimées les syndicats l'institut
les fontenois recommencer lentement
rêveur s'inverser et spar est quelque
chose de petit anodin personnel puis tu
développes par quelque chose de et
normes sociétales puis initiale que
c'est comme ça d'un petit je parle de ça
je parle de je parle de terrorisme je
parle de prostitution juvénile
le problème qu'avec les prêtres tout ce
qui est clergé je parle de je parle de
pauvreté je parle d'agression sexuelle
qui ont toutes les agressions qui ont eu
des dernières années fac c'est des gros
sujets mais je trouve que c'est la
partie phone c'est de prendre des sujets
qui sont pas nécessairement drôle de les
rendre hall en y ajoutant des
expériences personnelles et une vision
quand même assez assez réfléchi puis
rechercher faut que tu aies être capable
de rire des agressions sexuelles se pose
pas évident mais si tu arrives à le
faire c'est que c'est bien fait mais
seulement si tu peux me suis tu
travailles bien petit fait bien des
trucs tu peut rire de tout et jamais de
too soon ou de tuvalu tout parce qu'à la
base c'est saint maurice tu veux dire
c'est que tu traites un peu de
l'actualité est factice ici quelques-uns
comme kobe bryant qui est décédé veut
dire ça fait partie l'actualité c'est
normal d'en parler mais après ça c'est à
dire une niaiserie
tout le monde va dire le crime des caves
site ou alors est ce une manière de
traiter de sujets là de manière de
manière plus plus réfléchi longtemps
écrit dgac ce que j'ai pas encore écrit
de gager pas écrit de nouveau numéro
deux puis kobe mais alors beaucoup de
peines telles que j'apprécie énormément
fait du projet pas ressenti le besoin
non plus d'écrire et pas l'urgence n'est
pas et tantôt d'aller parler de courbit
mais tu vois comme cette semaine sera la
soirée est encore jeune je suis des
chroniques là bas puis j'ai vu j'ai vu
un reportage justement sur les
comportements environnementaux des gens
puis pourquoi ce qu'on n'arrive pas à
changer notre comportement
environnemental éco responsable puis
j'ai lu là dessus puisque j'étais fait
que j'en parle
non mais je sais quelque chose je viens
de comprendre pourquoi même mois des
fois je fais quelque chose ici comment
je pourrais tenir ce déchet là encore un
kilomètre qui trouve une poubelle ou
maître d'armé ou un recyclage vous le
mettre dans poubelle c'est l'espèce de
c'est logique quand je devrais le faire
mais il ya quand même une partie de toi
qui fais vraiment mais je pourrais juste
le mettre dans poubelles l'appui
j'aurais pu rien et maintenant c'est
d'expliquer pourquoi on hésite puis là
ça me tentait d'en parler fait que c'est
à l'état de faire la sourde est encore
jeune cool puis si les gens veulent se
procurer des billets ou est-ce conduit
où est ce qu'on va devoir ou est-ce
qu'on écoute ou est ce qu'on fait je lui
fasse mon site web tripeux w pour qui j
j fois ses ventes illégales site web
mehdi ben saïdane et toutes les dates de
chaud il ya toutes les les billets sont
là sinon
sinon je reste agréable vous aime suivre
chez souvent des spéciaux déçoit hip hop
comme on dit mais bon vidéo de swype à
face c'était 15 vins bières en cinq
minutes c'est pipi ça c'est vrai ça
c'est vrai puis la répétition le ch'ti
répète si jamais le même monde qui te
disent oui c'est sûr que tout le temps
quelqu'un de nouveau qui va acheter des
biens basquaise bière à chaque fois ci
ça en fait des sables disent long sur
facebook il ya aussi les liens mais je
pensais les lois les baisses et le site
web mehdi moussaïd hell.com et toutes
les infos nécessaires maintenant on vend
de la marche en plus hier j'ai carouge
des t-shirts de mettre flix merci
beaucoup de nous parler
merci à vous les gars c'était vraiment
hâte le satut désenflait un peu j'ai
complètement bancaire est qu'on souhaite
un prompt rétablissement
merci yahvé inertielle